hey guys morning so uh today is a big
day we are going to um
to take some positions live on amc on
gme so first
i want to do some technical analysis on
amc quickly to show you where are the
support levels where the resistance
levels what kind of move we can expect
today i'm going to show you how i will
personally uh treat this situation
hey morning bro
um i'm gonna explain as well why i think
we have some um
some relief that is coming on the global
market which is the reason why uh
trading stocks like amc makes more sense
now that the correction is maybe not
over i mean the global correction on the
spy but at least it's making a post so
we have some time uh i'm not sure if amc
will squeeze right away i personally
think we still have time but i think we
can see some nice moves happening today
so
let me first make a coffee quickly
all right so
let's do some technical analysis on amc
i'm here on the daily uh time frame guys
so i'm usually using the regular scale
but right now i'm back to the
logarithmic scale the reason being that
it's giving me better signals as you can
see
so here daily time frame i'm connecting
the highs between november 21
and
um
march 22. i'm here matching one two
three four five six seven eight
eight i have eight reactions here i
don't have any real consideration i have
a small consolidation okay
and then we have this massive move up
that happened yesterday and um and a
breakout above the 16.3 level so to me
this is a valid breakout it's not
perfect once again because we didn't
have the consolidation that we really
like to have when a breakout occurs
okay
yeah the noise is the coffee i was
making
oh right so how much time left 14
minutes
before market open because i want to
show you guys i need to take some
positions before market happens so i'm
going to explain why so i need to be a
little bit quick then we're going to
come back to it i'm going to explain
more in more details
um
so
so yeah so right now we are bullish so
we want to enter this trade i personally
already have some amc shares that i'm
buying in the simulating portfolio that
i'm showing you guys on this code so
this is one portfolio i have i have
different portfolio of course so today
i'm gonna show you this portfolio and
we're gonna um we're gonna buy more
shares in this portfolio
so first
uh bam bam bam
that's an espresso machine exactly
brother it's an espresso machine
so uh bam bam bam yeah
we need to find what are the support
levels so 1630 is an obvious support
because it was the breakout level then
we're gonna hourly time frames i have
the chart here that is prepared guys
on the hourly timeframe the trendline is
slightly different
but we have 16.3 as a breakout level as
well and here on this chart guys it's
very interesting
i hope you see well
uh i you need to to know where the
support level you need to find where we
had big volumes crossing some levels
okay so we knew already that there was a
support around 18
and when i checked on the hourly
timeframe the big volumes
look guys the biggest volume trading
yesterday was here once again i'm on the
hourly timeframe bam you see
this one and it's exactly when we
crossed this level around 18. so this is
telling me that 18 is the immediate
support we knew that already but this it
is confirming that this is where a lot
of bears had orders and they got
um they got lifted and so right now
those bears
maybe they're going to be buyers here i
don't know but they're going to be a lot
of bulls waiting at the support level
including myself
so
then you need to be more precise because
i'm showing you guys the first entry
level we're going to split our orders uh
on different levels on the way down to
buy shares today i'm going to show you
what position we're going to take
bam
so
we have our first level but you need to
be precise so here i'm using fibs it's a
bit early for now let's remove that
hey morning sandy
okay i'm explaining that brother someone
is asking what is the price to look out
i'm showing you guys the first level
we're going to split our orders in
different levels i'm going to be buying
today
so i need to be quick uh but yes 18
around 18.5 is our first support level
because as we've seen this is where the
most volume traded yesterday
uh
it was around the close as well so it
makes sense and then you need to be more
precise so you check in the past the
consideration you had and here you can
see that we have uh one two three four
four reaction at eighteen point
eighteen point five guys eighteen point
seven
eighteen point six okay so this is our
first first support level so we're gonna
place our first order here then i'm
gonna show you quickly where the the
other orders are gonna be
so we're gonna use fibs as you know guys
when we had a strong move up above a
resistance then you can use fibs and fib
ratios give you good
uh supports so the stronger the move and
the higher we close during the day of
the breakout the less likely it is that
we go to the lower ratios so here um the
most likely ratios are the
17.75 which is a fib ratio
and i can see that i have the one hour
moving average that is coming here as
well so it is not acting perfectly as
support as you can see we don't have
very clean reactions so we cannot use
this one hour movie simple moving
average just uh by itself but we can add
it to our analysis and here i would put
a second buying order around
17.75 something like this the next one
is going to be around 16 okay
i can even do four
okay next one 17 next 16 okay so we have
four buying orders now uh let's say
we're going to invest 10 000 u.s dollars
today okay so we have our four levels so
18.65
then
we said 17.75
then 17 and 16 roughly all right so then
uh you we need to find how many shares
we want to buy each at each level so
here we're going we're going to do a
dollar averaging which means that you
divide the total number of dollars you
want you want to invest so here 10 000
divided by the number of orders divided
by four and divided by the price okay
and this is giving you the number of
shares that you need to buy at each
price so i'm not exactly sure of those
three i'm gonna check more carefully but
the first one is good so we're gonna
place those orders first
right now before market opens
okay and as you can see uh if you do
a strategy like that when you buy on the
way down you absolutely need to buy the
same number of dollars and not of shares
so that actually you buy more shares on
the downside for the same risk as you
can see we're gonna buy 135 shares at
18.65
and if amc gets dumped today we are
going to sorry i have some issue
it was 185 shares
at um
at 16. so let me place the orders
first
so amc then i'm going to show you
something else
okay so first order we buy 125 shares
at
18.65
okay
all right i placed this holder for the
day okay the first order is placed so
that's good then i have some time
uh bam bam bam okay so 134 shares so
once again i'm here having a risk of 10
000 us dollars that i'm gonna buy during
the day
uh if we go to 16 if we don't i'm gonna
buy less and i'm gonna show you again
what i do because as you guys know i
used to work as a professional trader so
i like to control the risk
so
even if i'm bullish on amc i like to
keep a control of my risk so i'm going
to show you how
we can actually
control this risk so either we use a
stop loss but seriously i don't want to
use a stop loss below 16 no one wants to
sell below you know this uh levels if
you were around 30 it makes sense to use
a stop loss but here i don't feel
comfortable buying at 18 buying at 16
and selling everything at 15. i think
you guys can understand that so this
won't happen we won't be using a stop
loss on this strategy
but there are other ways that you can
have to actually control the risk
so the first thing i wanted to show you
guys i'm gonna do some technical
analysis on gme right now because on gme
we are trading at a premium and i told
you yesterday that i will give you guys
the ratio the usual ratio between amc
and jme i computed that i checked the
volume i'm going to show you all of that
guys it's very interesting and what
we're going to do to control our risk is
that we're going to
sell some gm shares on the way up all
right so we buy amc on the way down we
sell gme on the way up i've our of
course already have dmi shares so i'm
not taking a short position i'm just
gonna transfer a little bit of my gm
shares to my amc shares all right guys
so
uh to do that we need to know where are
the resistance levels on gme of course
so
my first order is placed on amc i just
want to make sure that 18.65 is the
right level
because we had a support just right now
in the in aftermarket so as you guys
know the aftermarket is not good to use
to trade because the liquidity is low
uh but it's still giving information and
i can show you that right now because
this level i had this level you know
already yesterday and as you can see we
had in pre-market a reaction here at
so what is the low 18.5 point 56
sorry yes so i want to be slightly above
that so 18.65
is a good level for my first buying
order okay guys so uh
bam bam bam the second buying order
because we don't know things can go
quickly what time is it 8 25 i have five
minutes left
uh the second bank order would be around
we said the fib ratio but you cannot use
a fib ratio by itself you need to
associate it with something else you
need to associate it with some trend
lines some uh you know other supports so
bam
we're gonna try to find some support
levels quickly guys i didn't do that
before so i need to check in the recent
past where i had some reactions i need
to find some moving average or whatever
something that is giving me um a reason
on top of the fib ratio to buy so i'm
looking for it guys maybe the 20 hour
moving average will be coming here so
for now this order
let's let's put it at 7 17.75
but uh i'm gonna probably amend that
during the day guys i'm gonna stay
uh all day with you i'm gonna try
uh because if amc gets dumped before the
close guys we need to control this risk
we're not gonna sell our shares but we
can do something else and i'm gonna show
that very soon okay so once again we are
going today to buy 10 000 usd off
amc shares
so
141 shares placed at 17.75
i place my order right now guys bam bam
bam
so
what was it
141 shares okay
bam
so by 17 17.75
okay i told you guys
it's not good to place your buying
orders at round
numbers so 17.75 is not a round number
but let's put it let's put it at 17.76
all right
just for the sake of avoiding this round
numbers okay so i have my two first
orders placed okay guys
so
we are good like that now
uh i want to show you something guys
first let's do some technical analysis
on gme quickly
bam bam bam
so i'm gonna get executed probably at
the up and on amc guys because i'm
placed at 18.65
okay so jimmy
let me just tell my discord that i'm
buying amc right now because we need to
know that of course
okay so i i placed my first two orders
guys
okay
all right so what else
two minutes left guys bam so jimmy
all right so jamie is gonna open the 130
so uh this is
this is a good level guys uh bam bam bam
this is a good level
and amc is opening flat so basically we
have a spread between amc and gme guys
so usually the ratio i'm gonna explain
that in more details but i did this
analysis yesterday uh depending on where
we are all right between 87 and 130 i'm
gonna show you why guys but amc uh gme
is usually um
six times bigger than amc i mean the
price of gm is usually six times bigger
so if amc trades at 18.65 which is which
is going to be the case at the open gme
should be trading at
113.7 guys and jme is going to open 130
all right so look at this difference we
are trading with a premium of 14 guys so
uh i'm gonna buy some amc but i'm gonna
sell some gme in the same time guys all
right so i'm taking the spreader so this
is so so this first order is not a real
risk okay because uh
when i'm buying on amc i'm gonna sell it
on gme so how many shares so we need to
uh 2 500 us dollars of gme so it's equal
to 2500 my notional divided by one share
okay so it's 19 shares okay guys
so i'm gonna do that right away
then
i'm gonna place this order i have of
course jamisha's so i can sell
here bam
and i'm taking the spread guys it's a
good trade so i'm just transferring some
some of my jimmy shares to my amc shares
right now so how many shots we said i
forgot 19 right okay
so 19 shares i'm missing the open no
okay we sell at 130
let's get dumped okay
i'm executing on amc 129 bam
okay i'm done okay so this is done guys
so the first trade of the day is done we
just bought some emc we sold some uh gme
so right now we still want to have um
an overall long position on the trades
we do today because we are bullish i'm
going to show you why we are more
bullish today than we were uh last week
i mean of course we had yesterday very
strong move up but there is also
something else on the global market that
is important
uh so i'm going to show you that let me
just check that my orders
are good
okay
okay
uh
so this is the first trade i want you to
do guys
let's buy more more amc
i want to increase the spread first
thing so for now i have a spread for
2500 us dollars
so i'm going to increase the spread to 5
000 us dollars once again we are trading
uh jimmy's trading with a premium of 14
i'm gonna explain why guys it's going to
be interesting for you to understand
that
so if jamie is training at 40 percent
and we go with 5 000 us dollars for this
position we can expect a p
a profit of 700 us dollars only on the
spread
so now
what is amc doing
cat
so now emc is going higher
uh
let me just take something guys because
i have some margin issues
okay but i'm gonna check that later guys
so first let's do some technical
analysis on jamie so jmu just opened at
uh 130
so i'm on the daily timeframe here
i'm using the logarithmic scale is it
the appropriate one let me go back to
the regular scale here
okay guys so yesterday the volume
trading was
the biggest volume we had since the 20
since august 24th guys we had
bam
we had 15 million shares trading
yesterday guys uh last time we had that
many shares trading it was once again in
august so nine months ago
so um so this is a signal that the
interest in gme is of course growing
massively guys okay
so what else do we have we can see that
uh this 50-day moving average that i
told you about yesterday guys was acting
as resistance
for the past four months since december
first when it got broken and then you
guys know what happened we had this
massive move down uh so since then
it was acting as resistance and quite uh
well as you can see here this whole
period we had multiple reactions around
10 of them just
bouncing back from this 50-day moving
average and yesterday it got broken on
the upside
with a very strong move so we have
already two information that are very
interesting is that it is the first time
we have such a big volume such a big
move since august 24th and we are taking
back the 50-day moving average which
didn't happen for more than four four
months so right now
uh where are our support and resistance
uh
levels so now first we need to add some
um
we need to check if we add some brackets
because whenever we have a huge volume
usually it means you have a breakout and
here the breakout i can find is this one
guys okay so you just connect
those highs that you have in this
consolidation and you can see that we
had a move across this level but once
again just like for amc guys um for
breakout to be good and reliable you
need to have a small consolidation
before the breakout look where the
consideration happened guys it happened
around 87. so this is the reason why
this move so you see for now we're
getting dumped uh this move is very wide
there's going to be a lot of volatility
because there is no um
no support area no um
you know to to to give some balance
between bulls and bears so here
everybody is disorganized uh traders are
buying selling you know it's it's it's
it's going to be a very volatile
day because of this lack of
consolidation that could bring some
stability to the press action so right
now
we are bullish because we are above this
115 level right this is the breakout
level this was also a horizontal uh
trendline that i had guys for very long
time in each of my gmu recap on discord
guys i i've always shown you this 115
level it's a very important level it got
broken on the downside and followed by a
very strong move uh close to the to the
87 level even slightly below that but
booze managed to take back control and
now we are again above this 115 level so
what we can expect
is um is a fight around 120 level that
is the immediate resistance as you can
see we opened uh just on it it got both
then sold now it's getting both again so
um my take is that we're gonna manage
here too okay so you see bulls are
taking back control guys for now so
let's see what's going to happen
so where are the buying levels on gme we
can do quickly the same analysis so once
again i showed you guys on amc
the buying levels
are
18.6 uh
18.65 so we got executed on this one
17.75
17 and then 16. i'm gonna uh give you
more precise level if we get below 17.75
but for now 18.65 is the first support
we got executed there 124 shares at the
open 17.75
is um the next support area so let's see
if we went close to that
okay so for now
okay so you see we we we had a small dip
below this 18 level that's why it's
risky to use stop losses on amc now for
now we are moving higher all right so
for those who didn't buy at 18.65 not
financial advice but it is still a
support level
okay
now gme so gme is uh going higher now
so uh the next resistance area
is at
140. okay why 140 because as you can see
so basically it it's a little bit a no
man's land be between
130 and 160 so my take is that if we
manage to close above 130 today uh
let's see everything can happen but it's
looking good um then i don't see any
reason we don't go to 160 maybe not in
one or two days but
there is no strong resistance before
that level but once again you guys know
that technical analysis is not an exact
science uh so it's just about
probabilities but whenever you don't
have any strong resistance in a range
usually the market is going from uh the
bottom to the top uh quite quickly as it
happened here for example between 160
years so we we dropped heavily and in
two days where we arrived in 130 then
the recovery was a little bit slower to
seven days and then again brutally back
here so for this reason we don't have
any real support level the only one i
can find is um
140 so um bam bam
bam
i'm trying to figure out how to solve my
margin issues
i'm gonna have on this account
okay i'm gonna think about that later
guys
so
i'm gonna give you buying levels for gme
for those who want to buy some jamie so
of course 130 is uh the pivot point so
it was resistance it is now support so
it makes it an entry level that is um
that makes sense
if
we drop below that which is possible
let's be prepared for everything so we
go on the hourly timeframe guys
okay i'm gonna read your questions just
after guys
okay
bam bam bam so on the hourly time frame
what information do we have first the
information we had is that we went to
147 in aftermarket all right so um
so this is telling me
that
this resistance at 140 that i had
makes sense okay but
it's not strong once again so we might
very well just brutally break it we are
coming close to it so let's see what's
going to happen
um
then if in the case we get uh dumped
today
the next support level so of course 115
is a support level but we have something
before that
okay
so we can take the fibs so you see for
example right now i'm taking the fibs so
what i'm doing is not very good because
i'm taking fibs on the hourly time frame
where we had some aftermarket so i
cannot technically do that so let's wait
to see where where is the high let's see
if we have a rejection around 140 level
not if we do then we can use fibs to buy
the dip on the way down we're gonna do
that
um
okay so for now the next support level
is 115
guys okay
so what else i wanted to show you
i wanted to explain to you why gm is
training at the premium and why it is
today better to me to
buy amc shares than gme shares
okay so the first reason
is
um
we need to find some equivalence between
amc and jamie so it's not that
complicated because those charts as you
guys know they are moving together
so we're going to do that uh on the
daily time frame so i'm here on the
daily time frame
bam bam bam
okay
and here i'm on the daily timeframe so
first the first equivalent equivalent
level that is very obvious is the low so
the low of amc was 14.5 okay you guys
remember that and the low of jme was uh
87. so that's why here i'm gonna put 87
for gme i did that before guys i
prepared that for you okay so i don't
know if you see well let me zoom in here
a little bit
okay let me know guys if you don't see
what i'm doing because i think it's
important okay so 87 is the low of gme
and the low of amc was 14.5 okay first
thing then we're gonna find uh some
other
levels where we had some um equivalence
equivalence between the prices so the
next one
is uh bam bam bam when amc was training
at 18 so here the um the upper band of
this
consolidation
gme was trading
no sorry when amc was training at 21 so
we are going to the next one
so it's here
okay i removed this level but when amc
was turning at 21
here as you can see we have a low that
is here another low that is here a
height that is here okay we do the same
thing on gme a low that is here on the
same day on the 14th on december 14th
another low and another high so you can
see that 130 on gme is equal to 21 on
amc okay so i
put that information here
okay 130 and 21 is the middle
pivot point of equivalence usually so
you can see right now gm is above that
amc is below that so you can already see
that gm is training at a premium then we
continue to do that the next one
is here guys
okay so when gme was training at 240 you
guys remember that when we almost
squeezed guys jimmy was here okay uh
twice
at 240 200 okay even 50. okay at this so
this was on november 3rd once again i'm
taking some very important points some
uh levels that got traded with a lot of
volume so either with multiple reactions
or uh when we had some massive moves so
here this is a very valid level to make
some equivalence so 18th
november 8th and november 22nd so amc at
the same time was training at 45 okay so
45 and
we said
okay
and the the last equivalent level i want
to give you guys is the high so when amc
was turning at 70 good memories guys
this was back in um in may may 2 or 21.
bam bam bam
in may
2021 so sure guys
amc was training around 70 okay 2nd of
june
gme at the same time was trading at 340
okay so this is my last equivalence
level so as you can see i have four
levels for gme four levels for amc and i
just compute the ratio guys look at the
ratio so i divide gme price
by amc price and i do that for all the
levels okay bam
so as you can see we have the ratio
between amc price
and gme price so when we are close to
the lows gm is usually trading six times
uh at a price that is six times bigger
than amc when we are around 130 this
price is usually 6.2 okay guys
um
when we are around 250 for gme and 45
amc it's slightly lower it's around 5.6
and when we are very close to the highs
we can see that amc at least that time
uh was
squeezing harder than jme but the reason
being that gme squeezed first before we
can discuss if it's if it is a squeeze
or not it's not the point of what i'm
showing you guys here but um what i want
to show you is that
wherever you are
not depending if you are close to the
lows or close to the highs gme is never
trading more than 6.2 times amc okay so
right now amc price
is trading at
so gme is really
going strongly higher 142
20
okay so 20.
okay so when amc is trading at 20
usually gme should be trading
6.2 times that and right now jamie is
turning 142. okay so we still have this
14 percent premium so the premium can
last for
a week
a month
but ultimately it's coming back okay so
for now amc is a bit late on gme all gme
is early
compared to amc i don't know so i have
shares on both of them but
as you as you have seen i've just
transferred some of my jamishas to my
amc shares
okay guys so let's go back to um
i want to talk as well about
the global market
okay
okay so now 130 is support guys so let's
see what's gonna happen but if we see a
dip we're going to buy back some gme
shares that we sold at the open to buy
amc shares and um
so that i'm gonna be able to buy more
amc because right now i have some margin
issues
bam bam bam and let's see where we can
go 106 160 is the next resistance level
guys once again why is it the major
resistance levels
let's see if we're able to reach this
level today
um but basically here
you can see we have a massive triangle
guys so those connections are not
perfect uh we have here
uh bam
this connection is really not perfect
but it's the best we can do
okay i can put it slightly like that
okay i'm just trying to connect those
four levels
and i have the 200-day moving average
that is coming as well
and
the last one i have is that here we had
many many reactions uh many rejections
between december 21 21 and jan 22 at
160. so 160
is a level that we get using a
horizontal line it's a level that is
coming from the 200-day moving average
and it's a
a level that you get using a downward
sloping trend line of this whole move
down guys okay so um
if we are getting close to that let's
see what's gonna happen
okay
probably a first rejection hopefully not
too strong and then if we are able to
consolidate close to this level it would
be looking very good
and once again guys this is the major
resistance level to take so for now
uh what is happening guys on amc and
jamie is definitely very good we can see
some uh very strong moves with some nice
volume but we've seen that before guys
remember we've seen that
uh
in august for example on gme we've seen
that in november
so it's not because we have those
strong moves that happen suddenly on big
volume that uh bulls are really back in
control on the long term we need to see
more guys we need more we need to have
some balance once again between bulls
and best for now it's a huge fight there
is no balance and after the balance
bulls need to take back control right so
this is gonna happen probably later uh
we're gonna of course money to that but
um
but for now we are definitely bullish i
think that 160 will be reached uh so if
gme is going to 160 amc should go guys
to um
to 27
should go to 27 guys okay
so let's see if it happens today i doubt
we see that let's be honest because
today gme is
more attractive than amc for now but
in a matter of a few days things can
change so let's see when we are able to
reach this level if we do and i think
that once we reach 160 on jme
so let's see i'm gonna do the same thing
okay so if jimmy's at 160
in this area we are okay around six so
amc should be trading at
yeah you see 27 okay guys so you can see
that uh amc is late on gme okay
all right
now i want to show you something else we
of course gonna keep an eye all day guys
on what amc and gm are doing
okay
i want to show you
the spy guys the spo is very interesting
because
um
let's think a little bit oh okay so here
i had an order on spy that i placed
yesterday with you guys
bam bam bam
let's see if it was executed
i know i'm still a little bit lower all
right so i still have my orders
i know i'm done on sp yes so i just
bought some spy shares
what level
446.05
okay
so i just bought some uh sspy shares i
have a stop loss at 443
now for where is my stop-loss
443.9
okay
so uh i'm using a stop loss on spy i of
course don't use a stop loss on amc and
gme
i'm a bit pissed because
i cannot
buy nc shares right now i need to solve
an issue
that i'm having but i'm gonna find a way
okay anyway for now
there are no no good levels to buy to me
once again 18.65 is still our first
support levels if we get back there
today um
it's
uh an interesting entry level to me
okay i wanted to show you what is
happening on the global market because
yeah once again guys as you know we see
some massive moves happening so it
started with bbig and mullen right it
started uh on friday
on yeah friday or thursday or whatever
end of last week and it happened
together with what guys it happened
together with the recovery of the global
market with s p 500 and nasdaq going
higher once again wisdom sometimes have
a negative beta which means that when
the global market is going higher uh
meme stocks like amc or gme
are no sorry when the global market is
crashing meme stocks like amc and jimmy
are going higher but this is happening
when we are in the bull run all right
guys if you are in a um in a bearish
cycle uh you won't see this negative
beta happening okay and this is not what
we have seen we've seen that when the
global market crashed amc and gme
crashed as well even more so um for now
we are training with a positive
correlation and this will probably
happen
uh
until so you see for example today now
we are in a bullish kind of cycle that
started last week so today we have for
now a negative beta because we are we
have s p training at minus uh 0.8
percent and we have mcn gme going higher
okay so this is a good example that this
negative beta takes place whenever the
bullish sentiment is back and i want to
show you why this the bullish sentiment
is back on the global market
and how long can it last and what
information we need to pay attention to
to know if this buddhist sentiment will
stay here so first
um
we had this correction so you guys know
that corrections develop okay let me get
rid of all this elliot with countings
you guys know that um corrections
develop in abc's right so
we are so in three waves so we had a
coming from 480
to 420 so this was the first leg down
then we had a move up which was a b wave
guys and i told you that many times in
my discord i told you i made video about
that don't get trapped by this b wave
because b waves are you know always a
trap you know you think things are uh
back to normal but actually they're not
and and usually b waves occur on low
volume so this is exactly what happened
here we had a massive rebound on low
volume so this was a trap i personally
sold here and then we had the c wave
okay so we had an abc the c wave didn't
go as low as i uh as
i thought but um
but we still had an abc so right now
maybe the correction on the global
market is over and we had this here
breakout above the 425 level okay we had
a strong move up involving at some point
some have a higher volume
gary's saying hi to you
okay so hey gary what's up bro
okay so you can see here we had this
strong volume training so it was just
below the breakout area when we arrived
on it
so this is a signal that you know things
are slowly starting to get back to
normal but it's not enough and then
yesterday we took back yes the 200-day
moving average okay so this was a very
important level this was the 445
446
level and um this was
this was taken back yesterday on not
very big volume but this is kind of
normal after a correction in the global
market that involves usually a lot of
volume we usually see some moves
happening first on high volume like we
had here during this breakout and
recovery process that is stunning and
usually impulsively and then we usually
have you know some we grind higher as we
say okay so this is a little bit what we
can expect from here but now that we
have taken back this level
uh
and as you can see we are now moving
higher we 446 is support this is where i
just bought right now
and uh we expect the global market to
stay so i take spy i can do the same
thing on triple q guys the levels are
350 for the support and 370 for the
resistance so on spy the support is at
445 446
and the resistance is at 457
so as long as we're in this range and we
will probably stay in this range guys i
let's see if we don't then we need to
adapt but we'll probably stay in this
range and as long as we are in this
range
um
we are going to to be in a good
environment for
um you know for buyers to take back
control on many stocks that got dumped
brutally so of course amc and jamie are
here milan was here bbig was here so i
think that this is what is happening you
know we have this bullish sentiment that
is coming back from this potential end
of correction and the money is flowing
back to what is cheap guys okay
so um
so the question is is it gonna last okay
are we really starting to um you know to
get back to the environment we used to
be before this uh whole
messy correction started in december 21
guys three
okay jan 22 even december guys here
uh amc and jimmy got dumped here guys so
between end of november
you know december 21 so we we were in a
very you know difficult uh environment
and the question is is it all behind us
so for now i would answer that we are
not out of troubles guys we are not out
of troubles yet uh and i'm only for now
paying attention to the global market
because this is what is gonna be leading
for the flows the flows are coming of
course from retail investors but retail
investors cannot do everything
by themselves you guys know that we have
when amc and gme started to squeeze
massively uh okay
i'm not sure it was a squeeze we
probably had some short covering on jme
this for sure amc uh
maybe a little bit i don't know but
uh what is for sure is that it was not
only retail buying they were asset
managers there were some big money
players all right and we need those guys
to be in the trade to uh push amc and
jimmy price at really high levels and to
you know combine their strengths with
retail investors and those guys there
probably they bought yesterday
um because once again the situation
looks good so they are all right let's
put some money in that and when they put
some money guys it's of course big money
um so i think they were there retail was
here for sure retail started i think
this uh this strong moves up we saw on
those meme stocks
um but
they're really
gonna you know increase the position on
not take profits if
things are really back to normal on the
global market if things are really uh
calm on the global market and what can
we be looking for because this is why
i'm here guys i'm here to tell you um
what
indicator you can have a look at to know
if this whole correction which is once
again very correlated to what is
happening on amc and jimmy is really
over or not and if it is then once again
the big money players are gonna either
keep keep their shares and not take
profits because those guys they buy and
they sell all right they don't buy and
hold uh so we don't want them to sell uh
and we don't we want them to increase
their positions and they're only going
to do that if they are kind of uh
convinced that
nothing else
bad could happen so of course we never
know if something bad can happen
especially in today's environment where
we have all these issues with russia
with you know inflation all of that is
creating a lot of tensions
so um
so let's see but we can uh have a look
at some levels all right so this is the
reason why i'm here so on spy the first
level is 460. okay it's the first
resistance level that is the breakout
level once again guys if you have a look
at the sp
with um you know
if you take a step back
and you guys know especially those who
are with me in discord guys i'm using
this trendline and i use this breakup
guys to take some bearish positions here
we made some
good money on um on this on on this uh
downside breakout but of course we had
stocks so it was not a full bearish
position but it was a protection that
was very very helpful and
uh this move down started with a
breakout below what level guys below 460
all right so this is the so and this
breakout has been retested already twice
so maybe now when we're going to come
back to it it's going to break i don't
know but what i know is that there's
going to be a fight there okay and we
want to see who is winning this fight so
basically what we want to see
is
the spy coming back to the 457 level
okay
and
breaking it with high volume why because
let me once again quickly show you what
are the different scenarios we can have
either we have an abc like we had and
then we have a massive fifth wave to the
500 level or sometimes corrections uh
develop you know uh longer corrections
and we can see that they develop
sideways doing a wxy a wxy guys is a few
a series of three abc patterns all right
so this is what we are looking for we
had one so right now we're doing a
second one abc
okay
and maybe we're gonna then at 460
brutally move down and even go to 380
yes you need to be prepared for that
this is a possible scenario if this
happens of course mcn gme are gonna get
dumped okay we're talking about the 15
percent move down on sp y so this is the
bearish case for now we are not there
but what we want to know we're probably
going to go to the 460 level but when we
arrive there we want to know
if we are able to do uh four and five or
not okay because we already have an abc
and if we are bullish it's not an abc
that we're gonna have you guys know that
moves up develop in five waves so we're
gonna have a one two
three
four so get rejected come back to 440
446
and then a massive fifth okay and this
fifth wave that will happen maybe in
april all right if i if i look at this
chart
um
this fixed wave is going to be the
answer so we want to see during this
fifth wave increasing volume and a vix
once again guys i'm talking about the
vix uh often because it's a good
indicator let's have a look at today's
uh vix
okay higher okay so that's not good guys
this is not a sign
of uh
off for now of a recovery that is
complete okay we have a vix that is
above 20 we can have some sharp moves
that moves down any time we need to be
prepared for that okay guys
um so if we see a vix below 20
if we see the global market trending
above 460 on spy and above
370 on triple q
um
with a nice volume during this breakout
okay
because we need to have a clean breakout
above those levels
then
and only then
i can tell you that
all the asset managers they're gonna be
what can i buy and they're gonna try to
buy everything they can and of course
they're gonna put their money in what is
hot because this is what they do and if
and it's not an if because we know how
it's gonna happen with amc and jamie for
sure if
triple q and uh spy go to those levels
so we are talking about the move up off
of
five percent roughly
so amc and gm are gonna take what
yesterday the global market took one
percent jimmy took 30 percent and amc 15
so we can imagine that if the global
market takes five percent amc and gme
can take between 20 and 50 okay so let's
call it 35 40
okay so let's imagine
that amc by the way mc is getting back
to the support levels guys
okay
we're getting back to 18.65
okay
so if we
uh imagine that we have a 40 move down
move up okay so i think we're basically
gonna come close to those uh very
important resistance levels that we have
so amc very strong resistance is around
it's an area i guess for now it's too
early to give you a precise level we
need to see what happens close to this
area but it's around 30 okay so even if
amc goes at 30 tomorrow
uh
anything can happen it can it can get
dumped okay but um
but it's going to be of course looking
very good if we arrived there that
strongly
what else i wanted to tell you guys
uh yeah and for gme this level would be
160.
so let's see
this is one scenario okay i rem i remind
you the scenario guys we are discussing
is that we are wondering if uh things
are really back to normal and if we can
start to move you know crazy higher and
really you know see those massive moves
that we saw before and like i said guys
this is going to be correlated to what
is going to happen on the global market
so i remind you the scenario we're
looking for and this is going to be the
trigger and i'm going to be here to tell
you that for now we don't see that guys
um we don't see that trigger for now
happening so um
it's gonna be if am sorry if spy goes to
460
okay 457
triple q goes to 370
amc 30
30 32 and jamie 160 okay so remember
those four levels let me write it down
okay so we have another equivalence okay
so equivalence
okay so amc
gme
spy
triple two okay so we want to see of
course that we're not gonna take
positions here but i'm just showing you
what levels we need to take back
okay
it's roughly that guys okay so remember
that levels let me zoom in okay
if you see all of those four
tickers above this levels
it means
that bulls are back in control
back in control in the world on
everything on equity it means that we're
gonna probably uh do some
very good moves up in the coming months
okay it's a long-term signal that is
going to be triggered if we see all of
that happening uh together and once
again we want to see an end vix below 20
okay
vixx below 20. it's important guys uh
okay
so i think that this is pretty it uh
let's go back
here guys what is amc and jamie doing
so amc is close to the support level
jimmy is doing better because jimmy just
the support level of jamie's 120
all right and amc and it's still a bit
above that let's go into 15 minutes time
frame guys
okay so this was at the open
so we got rejected guys where it's
interesting to see you can see we didn't
manage to make uh a close above the 140
level on the 15 minutes time frame so
for now this is the range we're having
so what we can expect is that
if we manage to close above that level
above 140 uh
we'll probably gonna see some so it
happened before but it happened in uh
pre-market okay so this doesn't really
count okay so but if it happens now this
would be a good information that uh
jamie can just go uh
no accelerate on the way up okay so for
now we have support here guys at 130.
so right now right now it is
accelerating so the premium is
bigger guys
okay usu is back
let me quickly have a look at the rest
of the market guys so we have oil that
is
moving higher as well
so the current the negative correlation
between oil and the market is still here
guys as you can see
because we have uh the s p 500
that is moving lower when the oil is
moving higher so
this is not very good for
for the economy for the global markets
so for now oil is moving higher so i
have some positions so i'm happy to see
that
okay guys so um
[Music]
okay let's have a look there is
something else that we didn't have a
look at guys and i want to take that
with you
is uh the options okay because the
option market as you know is giving you
a lot of information about what is
happening
on the market and once we know what is
the option market doing we can we are
able to compute the synthetic short and
we are able to compute the dtc and
yesterday guys i did that for gme we had
a dtc that was at 5.55
guys okay
so
uh
last time when we almost squeezed the
dtc was i'm keeping a record of all of
that guys and the dtc was at
bam bam bam
november here so we had a dtc at six
okay the third of november
as you can see guys here i'm keeping a
track
of the dtc and look at that guys okay so
we can see that since
uh february 22 the dtc bottomed at three
and is now moving higher okay so this is
kind of showing you that the probability
of a squeeze you can see this curve as
the probability of a squeeze and the
probability of a squeeze is increasing
okay this was yesterday's data so it's
interesting to see what investors did
since yesterday and of course with the
market moving it's gonna impact so i'm
gonna just refresh that guys
okay one sec
okay so it's slightly lower so we didn't
have since yesterday so i did that after
market close
so i'm a bit surprised that i don't see
an increase here to be honest i see 525
today
uh bam bam bam
i'm having all the maturities
uh but i did that after market closer i
i i i can see that
um yesterday during the day we had some
options that got bought because the last
time i did that we were at 4.5 so we had
a visible increase of the dtc but
between yesterday at the close and now i
don't see for now an increase on this
level i even see a small decrease which
i try to understand
uh what has moved
so let's put that here okay let's
compare
between today and yesterday okay so the
maximum synthetic short decreased
ah i know why
it's because the volume traded was huge
guys okay so once again the dtc is so
the short interest is bigger but as we
had more volume trading
the dtc is going lower all right
so um
bam bam bam
so it's interesting because we we need
to keep a high dtc even if the volume is
increasing right to keep short under
pressure
so uh we probably still had an increase
of the total number of options i didn't
uh
i didn't save this information
let's check today how many total shares
we have let's take the sum
of all of that this is the sum of all
the call options that we have on jimmy
okay
then one sec
okay so 17
million
shells okay equivalent this is the total
number of collapsions that we have on
jme
today
so i'm using live data so we're going to
monitor if this level is moving we're
going to monitor of course if the
synthetic shot is moving for now we have
six percent of synthetic shot so it's
not very big yet once again we can go up
to 27 guys okay if all the options are
in the money we can reach 27
of synthetic short the regular shot is
still 18
um
so we're going to keep an eye on this
synthetic shot once again you guys know
that for a squeeze to happen we need to
have all the ingredients right so i've
already told you
uh bam bam bam
i've already given you
those levels okay
so those levels to watch are
uh
parts of the recipe for squeeze okay we
need to have amc both 3d gm above 160 sp
y above 460 triple to above 37c weeks
below 20. once again guys uh you know
that um i'm often giving
a lot of levels like that of course this
uh this are my levels of course uh
anything can happen uh maybe we're gonna
be in the situation and the squeeze will
not happen you know i'm not saying there
is um you know a guarantee of that i'm
just saying that the probability
of a squeeze to happen if we have all of
that plus
the
option market that is back to what it
was
during uh the kind of squeezes we had
before
uh then shorts i mean i put myself in uh
you know in the shoes and they're gonna
really really feel bad they're gonna
probably start to cover
uh you know or buy calls or you know do
take some protections so uh so let's see
let's see what's uh
if we're able to to to reach this uh i'm
also keep an eye on keeping an eye guys
on this very out of the money uh strike
uh call
uh at 950 on gme because uh it was at 4
million before and you remember guys i
told you that we need to see this
rebuilding so that it is showing us if
the bullish momentum is back
and for now it is at 1.5 million
so it's it's a lot all right definitely
it's absolutely massive
i mean but
it has been three times bigger than that
before so we are at 30 percent of the
power
that we can have
in the stock you know kind of we can see
things like this maybe investors also
changed i don't know i'm just assuming
we have the investors that are going to
take the same actions for the same
reasons and for now we have only 30 of
those actions that have that have been
taken compared to the past okay i'm
gonna do the same thing on amc
okay let's keep an eye on what is
happening here so amc still in this
range between 18.65 and 21 guys the
first resistance is at 21.
so let's see if we're able to go above
that level jimmy is coming close to the
140 level guys so once again it has been
we we've never closed i'm only 15
minutes time frame let's quickly switch
the time frame to see
if we have some better signals
bam it's not easy guys to do ta on those
stocks
on a very short time frame but we still
have some signals so of course those
signals need to be taken with a grain of
salt but uh they are still used by some
inves investors to you know uh to do
their training so here for example we
are going again above 140
okay
i'm trying to find the level you know
i'm a bit disturbed because of this um
this was the aftermarket yesterday
okay
i want to see where this consideration
takes place once we have a consideration
it's going to be easier to take a
decision all right guys
okay
sp y has rebounded
on the support
okay so that's good
we want the spy absolutely to hold above
the 445 level all right we don't want
the bullish dynamics to be broken okay
this is important guys
uh bam bam bam
okay so jimmy is going above the 140
level so that's very nice let's see if
we're able to close above that level
this is where you can see yes this is
where booze and bears are fighting right
now at this very moment
okay we have the oil
that is ripping
this deck still doing good
okay so i have a question about
consideration a consideration is taking
place it it depends on on on the number
of candles all right so here for example
i had three candles so it's not really a
consideration here we have definitely a
consideration all right for example
okay so it's not a very good example
because i'm here using some uh pre and
aftermarket data
but
it's still a good example in terms of
candles you can see the price was stuck
here with around 10 candles so this is a
consideration and then when we close
above that consideration we have uh the
move up that is following all right this
is the theory of course it's not always
happening like that
we can see here the same thing happened
a little bit we had this consolidation
at the you know 108 level this was the
20-day moving average if i remember well
and then it got broken and then we moved
higher right so here we are looking for
this consideration but this
consideration is not clean because it's
happening on um on big moves okay so
this is not a pattern that is easily
treadable right
so we need to wait a little bit and see
if we have some easy some patterns that
are easier to trade
we can also check if we have some moving
averages that are supporting the price
action so here for example in 30 minutes
time frame
we have one okay
so we can use that as well
if
you know for those who today want to uh
get in
some jimmy shares once again not
financial advice
uh but
the first support is 130 but after
you know
um in one hour
the 120 level is not going to be the
first support the first support is going
to be given by the 30 minutes uh simple
moving average
that will follow the price action on the
way up okay guys
and i'm thinking
okay guys let me quickly have a look at
my discord
okay
okay we can quickly have a look guys so
what you want to see because now let's
wait a bit let's see what the price
action is doing let's see if we're able
to close above this 140 level uh on amc
we're still uh close to the support
level at 18.65
so this is the first support
uh for now
we got rejected around 21 which was the
first resistance so
um what is likely to happen is that we
you know stay in this range maybe
oscillate a little bit here uh then
let's see we need once again to have
some consolidation to help us guys here
uh let's see on the 15 minute time frame
if we have something
okay you see we are consolidating but
it's not a real consideration okay
because we are considering
with very strong moves so
it's not easy to use that
as a trigger all right even if we close
above right now uh you know 20 or the
the reason why we had here even 21 it
wouldn't be a very good signal all right
the good signal was given for example
here but once again this was this is not
a good example because i'm here using
some pre and after uh market data that's
why the price was not moving but i'm
telling you that if you see that that
kind of pattern you know this kind of
consideration when the price is just
dying at the level on low volume then if
we have a move across those support or
resistances then it's followed usually
by a continuation move uh in the same
direction okay so here we don't have
those patterns i can go even to the five
minutes time frame
try to find some
you see even on the five five minutes
time frame for now the price action is
disorganized so um
so the only way to trade that is to find
some support levels and to use it for
entry all right
so here once again the 30 minutes time
frame is giving a good support level uh
that is
you know
coming at eight 18.65 so the same right
so it's gonna follow the price action
same on the way up so we need to pay
attention to this level if it's broken
on the way down it is not good as well
guys
okay
um
okay yes let me quickly have a look
so
we can quickly check yeah what the other
stacks we were monitoring yesterday are
doing guys
so we can have a look at milan some
million guys is um he's a bit stuck here
uh i think that the reason behind that
is that um we have a little bit the same
investors that
trades uh that trade mulen amc gme and
bbig
so uh we first had some strong moves
happening some strong moves up happening
on uh mullen and bbig
and then i think we have a transfer okay
uh investors took profit and went to uh
amc and gme so i think that this is what
is happening and this is the reason why
today we see those stocks just you know
not
dropping okay because we still have some
bullish momentum
uh
you see but yesterday the volume was
very low
let's see today we we just have
investors not interested as much as they
used to be in those two stocks which is
understandable bbig is even dropping but
um so let's first do mulan so mulan is
still
so here for example we have a
consolidation that is starting to form
right but we need at least
three or more three or four more candles
but if we are able to consolidate just
below 360 and then
on mulan and then we have a move across
360. it will it would probably be
followed by a move in the same direction
now if we check bbig guys uh bbh is an
interesting situation
because to me
if i use this trend but once again this
trendline has not been respected here uh
we are
just finding some support around this
level okay so we are above 280 and we
have we managed for now to stay above
that level so boos are still in control
and this is the kind of pattern that is
starting to create
um
an interesting opportunity for training
because if we see this consolidation we
know where are the support levels okay
so for now we had this 280 level that
was support created by this trend line
but it was the only
only method we could use to find 280 as
a support if we have another method it
would make 280 a stronger support so
then we can use it
to buy with a stop loss just below
okay
so
for now it is a little bit too early
so i don't think
i mean
we don't have those strong moves down
happening so i think that this is just a
pose and that is gonna probably keep uh
going higher later maybe in a few days i
don't know
but i don't see any strong
moves from the bears because as you can
see we are consolidating but very close
to the highs so this is a good
information that we can keep to know
that booze are still totally in control
and that we have this you know transfer
from some investors to other investors
we have some profit taking happening uh
and in the same time we have new buyers
that are entering the trade okay so this
is a healthy
um process that is happening during bull
runs and whenever it happens close to
the highs
of a move then it makes this move more
likely to continue all right if we first
dump and then consolidate then it's like
you know 60 40 i would say depending how
low we dump but when we consider dates
so high which is happening here uh it's
usually um a good signal sent to
investors that are going to keep
entering this trade okay
okay
so what is the strong resistance line on
jme now for now it's not easy to say the
best one i can have and i think i showed
you that guys at the beginning of the
video
is
the 140 level and you can see that this
is where we have this fight that is
happening right now uh 140 because
i don't have much many reactions in this
range between 130 and 160 but we have
here two laws okay so it's enough to
make it a level that investors can use
you know for example i uh i i have seen
that level and this is uh the only level
i see in this range that can act as
resistance and for now it is acting as
resistance okay
let me get rid of that so once again it
is never easy to know when this level is
broken and once again if it's broken but
without the consideration before the
signal sent is not strong all right so
even if now we close above 140
um we can very well correct and come
back to 120 tomorrow and then move to
116. okay so we need to have once again
guys and i'm explaining that very well
in my course if you are interested guys
the link is in the description of this
video um because you need actually to
use a lot of indicators combined
together so volatility momentum and
volume information combined in the same
time to find those uh patterns that are
actually credible and that gives you a
good results and here guys
it's not the situation i mean so of
course it's bullish there is no doubt
about that you can just watch look at
the volume and uh and look at what
happened on the medium term but on the
very short term
anything can happen and if we want to
have information on what is going to
happen tomorrow then we need to play a
difficult game we need to do some
technical analysis on gme using the 15
or 30 minutes time frames and uh you
guys know that here we have a lot of
algorithms that are managed by hedge
funds that are here to trick you guys
all right when you go to those short
time frames
you find yourself in uh you know
a difficult environment where
you have a lot a lot of information that
are coming from different types of
investors and you know what makes
technical analysis working is that uh
technical analysis is actually using
investors emotions to
um anticipate
what they can do depending on what they
did in the same situation in the past
but when you are facing some algorithms
that don't have emotions that you know
are just calibrated using the patterns
all right as well you know they
calibrated using price past information
as well but
the thing is that they don't have
emotions they don't panic they don't
they don't formal right those algorithms
they're machines and it's very very hard
to
use a market where you have some
information coming from machines and
some information coming from humans and
you know apply the same methods so this
is the reason why technical analysis
sometimes is not working at all and
sometimes it's working very well so uh
the only thing i can tell you is that
whenever you have a time frame and a
stock or a crypto whatever that is
giving you good signals good reactions
and that you can see that the patterns
you are looking for are usually working
and giving you good results then it is
appropriate to use technical analysis
and uh i can of course
uh do my best on the 15th time frame on
jme but i know guys i know that it's
very very tricky and that it's hard to
give
good and reliable seagulls all right so
for now the best i can tell you
is on the 15 minutes time frame okay
because the 15 minutes time frame and
i'm saying that since the beginning
is the one
that is apparently for now
uh creating this pattern that is slowly
starting to
appear with a resistance line at 140
that has never been uh crossed with a
closing level all right guys so for now
we have always closed below 140. so if
we are closing above
it would be a signal but once again
depending on how long this consideration
is lasting if this candle is closing
above the signal would not be so strong
but it's still a signal that
bulls
will will enter more it means that all
the bells sitting here that are actually
pushing back the price action lower um
don't have any more shares to sell right
this is what it would mean okay so uh
bam
and the 30 minutes time frame is giving
good information as well because as
we've seen we have this uh 20
uh
20 period moving average on the 30
minutes time frame that is acting well
as support guys okay so for now we have
support
coming from this so at 100 right now
129.5
and resistance at 140 okay so this is
the only thing i can tell you for now
guys and as you can see the 140 level is
you know acting
we have a fight happening there all
right on amc it's
not that obvious guys we we we went to
the 20 level
um
20 something
and it got dumped strongly okay so for
now clearly today uh gme is doing better
than amc so the premium that i showed
you guys before is increasing all right
so
one day or the other
this prm is gonna come back once again
the analysis i've done here guys is some
analysis
that is used
on different assets and that is
relying on the fact that whenever big
volume is traded it means that investors
a lot of investors agreed upon a price
and whenever you take different levels
where you have a lot of volume traded
you have so many investors that have
this levels in mind okay
and
um
and when they they need to choose what
to buy between mc or gme they're gonna
remember those levels and for this
reason and asset managers are using
spreadsheets as well to monitor that
guys i can tell you uh so everybody
knows today that gm is trading at a
premium so of course
it doesn't mean it's gonna come back
right away but
sooner or later it's gonna come back so
for now we have amc training at
bam
19 gme 138 guys
so let's check
okay 17 premium guys okay 17 premium
so um
let's see how
this can evolve but for now jimmy is
doing two percent better than amc
in comparison of uh notional wise of
course guys so it's not exactly on the
share
price
okay what else we have here we had a
rebound on the spy guys that is still
you know holding above this levels i
remind you guys yesterday we took
uh
we took a position here
and for now it's it has acted perfectly
as support guest so let me remind you
that
this was the trade we took yesterday bam
it was here so we were buying at 446.05
with a stop loss at
443.9 okay
and
right now
what was the
okay so you can see we went slightly
below we went 445.6
but we are still far from the stop loss
we had guys and this is a technique that
i was using a lot when i was a trader
in banking okay you just need to find
some
strong support levels
and you buy just above the support level
and you put a stop loss just below uh
this support level ideally below a
shorter time frame consolidation so here
we've done that together yesterday and
we put the stop loss around 443 so for
now this trade is doing well
what else do we have
we had silver as well guys i remind you
here we took a position as well
so for now this is rather flattish
uh
the reason behind is that on the daily
timeframe we had this breakout guys that
occurred here
uh on increasing volume
then we had a re-test and now we are a
little bit consolidating just above this
trend line guys
but um
but bulls are clearly in control here on
the long term
so let's see if uh we have this positive
reaction that we expect but this is uh
to me a very nice situation of uh to
take a long position so
this is the reason why i took here a
long position on silver so let's see if
this is going somewhere today or not we
are up to 60 bps but yesterday we were
down one percent so this position is
still rather flattish but we have time
it can happen any time
okay thank you brother okay so i'm gonna
have a bit to look at your questions
guys
uh for now
okay of course we gonna keep an eye all
day guys on amc and jimmy
still rejected at 140 for now
amc still close to the support a bit
weak today i was expecting more from amc
to be honest
uh let's monitor that yet guys let's see
what we can do but those stocks are
doing really great compared to the rest
of the market that is dropping a little
bit
uh we can go do something cool guys we
can go and compute the correlation that
we have between spy and meme stocks amc
gme but first i'm gonna
have a look at your question
thank you so much wesley
i'm reading your your things guys
yo bro
[Music]
okay i can do quickly mvis
let me know guys if you want me to check
other stocks
but i think i gave you already a lot of
information today
i'm of course going to keep an eye on
everything that is happening
so mvis yeah remember this one
okay
so
let's see
let's see what we have
okay so first should i use yeah i will
use logarithmic scale so as you can see
here
on mvis
we are having a nice behavior all right
let me put that even lower because we
are here consider this is a good example
of consolidation
that is happening on low volume okay
but
so as you can see we have in the past
week
multiple rejections at the 475 level and
right now we are really you know coming
close to it with uh some very small
moves and we are staying you know where
we are staying very close to this level
so uh it means that you know bulls the
buying power is just located below this
resistance
so you know it's really putting pressure
on bears
so first thing now we know that best
they feel this pressure so they have
stop losses probably above the 475 level
so
if we manage
to but they are they probably have some
selling orders at 470. this is the
reason why the price action cannot go
above that level but if we manage to buy
so if investors manage to buy more
shares than what the buyers have to sell
then what's going to happen is that
buyers are going to be buyers as well
all right so this is the phenomenon that
is creating a breakout so here we are we
are a little a little bit in this
situation but it's on the short term all
right if i have a look at the bigger
picture i'm gonna connect
the highs that i have here and i have
one two three reactions so it's not a
lot
okay that's why i had this other trend
line
when i say it's not a lot it means that
the trend is not very visible and here i
don't have any good trend line okay so i
don't have a lot of information
a part of this blue trendline that is
here that is giving me a level at 550
guys so what i can say is that below 475
uh bears are still in control okay
they're rejecting the balls if we go
above 475 we're gonna be in a neutral
area
probably gonna test the next resistance
quite quickly so around this blue trend
line so around five ten five fifty
uh
then we're gonna need to see what's
gonna happen maybe a consolidation and
only after that
after breaking out above that level we
can uh see both back in control on the
long term right
uh if this happens the next resistance
is six where we usually have a rejection
even after a good breakout when you use
inclined trend lines like that you often
see this rejection okay and then we have
uh the follow uh the the continuation
move that happens after the breakout
okay so mvi is done hey morning brother
okay h y m c i can have a look at that
[Music]
okay
so i'm connecting the eyes that i have
here
and
okay i like this trend line this
trendline is the one that has acted as
uh resistance on the way up here on
march 16th
uh we went there once got rejected went
there a second time got rejected again
uh and right now so on the long term
buzz and control
okay
you can see that this situation is not
perfect because this consolidation is
here happening
on
uh
quite far from the resistance okay so we
want to see a consideration close to the
resistance for a good pattern to be
forming here we don't have it so i would
personally stay away from that the only
thing i would do maybe if i wanted to
get in there in there i would
first i would wait and see if we can
have this consideration here and then a
breakout or i would try to find some
lowest support where where we had the
last consolidation but even here we
don't have any
good consideration maybe around this
level around the 0.8 level okay
so 0.8 seems to be the first support
level
uh
but it's not very strong
so yeah this is all i can say about that
i'm not bullish on this definitely
and guys we can have a look quickly
at
the negative beta that we you guys know
we see during uh the squeezes because
this is one more information that we can
add to our analysis
we can see that if the correlation so
let me first show you quickly what i did
here
so i'm retrieving
uh prices from amc
from gme for now and spy
okay i'm retrieving
last year prices
okay
and i'm computing the returns
what's up gabriel today what do you do
um
i mean nothing much
um
like yesterday i was using 9k today i'm
saying i'm winning 9k okay flat over the
two days okay okay okay we can
see more later but it's basically more
like a pianelli on crude oil and silver
okay because crude oil is coming back
you still have the long position
silver you still have long and how is
the spread between silver and gold doing
today
i would say flat okay
because
i mean it shows something now but
i would i would ignore it i would just
say it's fast okay okay so quiet day for
now yeah okay cool
cool cool all right guys so here here we
go
okay so you see this chart i know you
don't understand anything but let me
explain okay
so to make too much information okay so
bam
monster creation
okay so what we can see on this chart
is
the green curve that is here
no sorry it's not good let me
ah okay i have it because you see it's
not a monthly correlation i had only
five days so that's why the data is not
smooth and we don't see anything okay so
we need to take 22 days so we have here
five so 22 plus 22 44. here we go bam
bam
okay
and now this is the monthly correlation
okay
so once ah
now it's better all right so
here guys on this chart
stay with me because this is interesting
and this is one more information that we
can monitor to know uh if we are in an
environment when the squeeze is likely
to happen
so we know that whenever we had those
massive moves on gme so here for example
i'm having the jan
20
1
move you can see the green curve guys is
the returns all right so here we did 400
return this is the monthly return okay
and we can you can see that we have
those strong spikes happening sometimes
here the green curve is is going higher
so basically
here as well and you can notice that
whenever we have those strong
returns so whenever the green curve is
high we usually have the blue curve that
is low so what is the blue curve the
blue curve is the correlation so it's
the beta between the spy and gme
and it's interesting to see
that
when it starts to go down
then we are in an environment so
basically when we have a few days when
gm is going up and the global market is
going down then in the past it happened
four times guys um
i don't have the chat where i'm showing
you each time it happens but i did that
before remember
and uh whenever we see this correct
correlation that is starting to drop so
whenever we have a few days in a week or
in a month where
when gme is going is trading with a
negative correlation compared to the
rest of the market or amc then we've
seen that those strong moves up are more
likely to happen okay so and for now
look at the correlation the correlation
is very positive
okay
it's very positive is around 50
why because we were we are coming out
from an environment when uh gme
amc and the rest of the market
got dumped okay so for this reason when
everything is moving down together
especially with strong moves this is
creating a very positive correlation so
we need some time because i'm here
taking a monthly correlation we need
some time for this monthly collection to
start to drop and a day like today is
going to help it okay you can see
yesterday correlation was 61
and today is
50 and it's gonna be even lower tomorrow
because i'm going to have two days move
on top of that
okay guys so for now one more indicator
we pay attention to the correlation and
it's still positive i can do it quickly
with amc and then we go back to the
chart guys don't worry
yes and come on guys give me some likes
only 62 likes guys
we need to
reach 100 likes quickly
bam bam bam so
uh yeah the coronation
so same thing guys no surprise all right
no surprise the amc spy correlation is
uh same thing guys close to 60 okay so
very close to gme spy correlation by the
way and we are not surprised to see that
okay so
what is happening so for now gm is
coming back guys to this
and you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
just
let's wait a bit here
okay guys i just need to check something
i'm coming back
i'm trying to solve this margin issues
ahead
okay cool
okay guys i'm back pam pam pam okay so
spy 2 420 again
uh so i've answered that question before
uh i personally bought at 446 today
uh i'm bullish right now on the short
term but on the medium term i'm neutral
i don't know what's going to happen
around the 460 level and it's very
important to monitor that guys
uh before that you know it's better just
to buy the deep sell the rip right we're
in this type of market
it's not i think a good idea to buy high
unless you have a tight stop loss just
like i've done today guys i bought at
446 stop loss 443
okay
we can see amc is coming back to the
support area guys i'm hesitating to
getting more shares here but we had a
strategy so i need to stick to that i
remind you the strategy
that we have today
i'm not gonna increase the um
the spread
on amcgme because this is creating some
troubles on my margin
account
because i'm using some leverage on the
positions i'm having okay so whenever
they see a spread they charge a margin
all right it's like that so here
basically for now we bought some mc we
sold some gme so we didn't buy anything
we only buy bought some spy
so amc is coming back to this level
so i'm going to get some shares here
guys
because
once again on the 30 minutes time frame
we saw that this is a good level so
let's get in some shares
at this level instead of 17.75
so we change a little bit the game plan
but uh because we need to adapt to the
situation of a margin account it's like
that okay
so give me a sec
okay
bam so
where is amc trading right now guys
18.80
okay so we have the uh 20
uh period moving average on the 20
minutes time frame we've seen that it's
the best one to use that is right now
acting as support we are concentrating
here so we might very well drop below
that but it would be good news we would
be able to buy more shells lower all
right so the question is where do we
place the order we're gonna go slightly
above the uh 20 day moving average so
we're gonna go uh a 20 pure moving
average on the 30 minutes time frame so
we're gonna go to
18.74 this is a good level
so
we said 141 shares guys at this level
okay
so bam
okay
okay one sec guys i have some connection
issues
let me know if the live is working well
guys if you see me well
okay
my interactive broke your account just
shut down okay now it's back okay cool
all right so buy
140 shares
142
let's stick to
the good numbers
okay so 134 we redo the same trade
okay because the one we did this morning
was not a full buying position so now we
have another opportunity to get in some
shots so let's do that
124 at
18.72 we said
okay
bam
okay and we still have our 140 shares
placed below okay we are just executed
here on
at 18.72
so that's good
so let's see what's going to happen now
so i'm going to 30 minutes time frame so
we've seen that we had sometimes a small
move below this support right now we are
testing the support so we have as you
can see guys a fight between bulls and
bears
um
bears has have a slight advantage here
because
we have tested this level multiple times
as you can see one two three four five
six times
so uh the more level is tested the more
pressure is felt by the camp that is
defending this level all right so here
those are buying here i bought here
because i wanted to buy something today
but if i had bought before i wouldn't
have bought again here because once
again
i would feel that bears are you know
knocking at the door multiple times and
this is um
this is creating
some risk of a breakout and here if we
close below uh 18 points
roughly 18.5 okay on a 30 minutes time
frame uh
i think that it would be followed by a
move down so then we would go probably
to the next support level around 17.75
so let's see i'm happy if this happens
because once again the idea today is to
load up to load some shares uh we said
that we have 10 000 us dollars to invest
so for now okay we took some position on
the spread okay that is uh losing two
percent
so no no big deal and we just entered
enough on our first trench on amc okay
today once again we buy amc not gme guys
because we have this premium of 17 right
now let's check the what is the premium
now guys
okay the amc is trading at 18.83
gme
124.67 so
18.83
124.47
okay ah you see so we are back
we're back to the uh same level as we
were before we have again 15 percent of
premium okay slightly more 15.5
uh so
so this premium is back it was as you
saw 17
uh during the day when gme was close to
140
uh so we can see that you know of course
this premium is not
stable
but i can tell you guys that this
premium in average is zero all right so
for now gm is trading at a premium
uh let's see next week guys but maybe
you know i give it a month for this
program to be back to zero we're gonna
see that okay
so we bought some shares for now we have
a positive reaction so that's pretty
good like i said again this level is in
danger right now to me because it has
been tested six times but it has been
well defended by bulls uh here
personally uh was
uh amongst the bulls that were defending
this level i bought some shares
and this is
to me how um how the press action should
be analyzed okay
and i will not buy shaz again if it gets
back to it so i don't know what the
other bulls are gonna do but at some
point
we're to be out of mini ammunition at
this level and we're going to retreat to
the next support level so i hope this
will hold
but let's see
let's see jamie guys
again
so what is happening here is
um
is still the same guys uh let's go into
15 minutes time frame
okay guys and give me some likes guys
only 69 likes come on hit that like
button guys
and i'm going to show you a uh something
very interesting as well
so
maybe i'm going to make a break and come
back for uh for the close
but
depending what happens if we are ripping
i don't need to
but if we are dropping and we go to the
16 level okay i don't know it's one
scenario i don't think it's it's going
to happen but let's imagine it happens
[Music]
then
then what we will do because once again
i like to control the risk guys i come
from
the banking industry we've been taught
to do that and this is what i'm trying
to bring to you as well i know that you
like to buy and hold but you can buy and
hold and control your risk
so in this situation
uh it's a bit early to talk about that
but i can already tell you that it would
be
uh selling a covered call all right if
today let's do this scenario now even if
it's definitely not looking like that we
never know what's gonna happen so let's
imagine
that today we close at 16
okay
so if today we close at 16 guys it would
be a massive
uh pullback that is too sharp if it
happens today a pullback that is
happening you know slowly is is good and
usually brought back but if we have a
sharp pullback like we had for example
uh you know
on bbig we had this example let me show
you that guys remember that this is some
tip i'm giving you if after breakout you
have a putback that is too sharp then
it's usually uh followed
by a fake out okay
as simple as that
we had this
happening on bbig here guys okay you see
bbig broke out here i remember i was
covering that in jan 22 guys 18th of jan
breakout without consideration once
again so this is not a good breakout and
then we got brutally rejected okay
and whenever you get brutally rejected
like that then you know it's hard for
boos to take uh to take back control so
if on amc we see that happening okay
once again i don't think it will happen
but let's imagine it happens
then if we have both ten thousand us
dollars of
uh shares on the way down
uh we know that
it's a good position to keep and we of
course don't want to stop this position
on the way down but what we're going to
be able to do
as
this signal would probably mean that
even right now you can see as we don't
have any signal of an incoming squeeze i
mean we have a little bit early signals
uh but everything is not here yet
uh even if it's starting to come and
it's looking good but it's not here yet
so if we on top of that we have a strong
move down happening today uh this will
uh be one more reason to think that this
scenario this you know squeeze upset
squeeze scenario will not happen right
away so if we had both 10 000 u.s
dollars of shares
we don't want to sell it and we know the
squeeze will not happen right away what
can we do guys we can sell some calls
all right so for example we would go
to
i'm just giving you an example because
it will depend exactly on everything
that happens but
the volatility is very high today
because of the strong moves that we had
yesterday market makers are scared
option market makers so when they are
scared they just sell the volatility
at a higher level just remember that the
volatility um is what makes the price of
the call options so they know that the
day like today they're gonna need to you
know provide a lot of call options to
retail investors and whoever wants to
buy some collapsing
on amc on amclgme and so they're gonna
uh increase the volatility which is a
parameter they use to price the call
options higher all right because they
need to provide a bid and an offer so
they want the offer to be as high as
possible uh so they're gonna increase
the volatility okay this is what they do
to protect themselves so because they
know that everybody is going to buy
those options but the smart thing to do
a day like that is to sell this option
because you sell it at a premium okay so
this is once again a trading move this
is what i was doing once again i was an
option trader guys so a day when things
are moving strongly like that is not a
good day to buy options so once again as
we are buying shares because it's a good
day to buy shares right we
gonna use call option as a protection
for investment because we don't want to
use stop losses
if things don't look good at the close
so let's see how things look but
we're gonna be able for example to sell
we don't need to go too high we can go
to the you know
24 strike
for example
on june
pam
it's not amazing 21.
okay we can go for example to the 21
strike so i know it's a
short strike but we're gonna be able to
buy it back later if the situation looks
better so if today we have a strong move
down and we buy shares we're gonna sell
a june
17 21 call and we're gonna cash in three
dollars of premium okay
and with this three dollars of premium
our investment which would be done at an
average price
off
here we go
an average price so let me here compute
the average price of that
so
is not working okay
okay 17.3 okay guys so we're gonna buy
at an average level of 17.3 if we are
executed executed on all our orders
today and by selling a call um a june 17
21 call we cashing three dollars premium
which means that
minus 3.2
this will
give you give us protection
until
14 okay so it's the same thing as as if
we have bought our shares at 14 and of
course if amc goes to
50 we're gonna be very disappointed but
if amc goes to 21 which is once again
the next resistance level after 18
we're still gonna be able to get to make
so we would have bought
how many shares this number of shares
that we buy at an average price of
14 because of the three dollars
discount we get by selling the call uh
17.3 minus 3.2
uh so
so 21 minus 14 okay
so we're still gonna be able to make
four thousand us dollars so it's not
impressive i agree
but it's still some money that we make
with a risk that is very much under
control because if we buy at an average
level of 14 the worst case scenario guys
is what amc goes back to eight okay this
this is the really worst case scenario
so in this scenario we would have lost
um
so same thing
so this
okay so the sum so the total number of
shares we bought in average at 14
and we
and if mc stays at four we would have
lost three thousand five hundred us
dollars in the worst case scenario so by
doing that you control your risk and
most likely amc will not be trading at
eight forever okay
so i think that it's a very reasonable
risk and once again the idea is not to
sell the score the idea is to buy and to
see a rebound today okay if we see a dip
and then boost take back control and in
this situation we would have bought
uh 580 shares
at an average level of 17.3 and we are
well positioned to see what can happen
next okay
so getting back to the charts guys what
is happening nothing much for now we are
still you know
uh let me go back to the 30 minutes and
from gme will come soon guys to this
okay it's gonna be interesting gme
might
say it's got it's gonna happen maybe in
30 minutes i don't know gme might happen
might come
soon
find some support at this uh 30 minutes
moving average
so i want to play the spread between amc
and gme so i will not buy amc gm shares
unless i use a tight stop loss just
below this level okay we can do that
guys we can make a funny trade
once again i'm gonna use a stop loss on
gme sorry about that guys i know that
for some of you it's not good but it's
the only way i can
take a position on gme keep by keeping
my spread and controlling my risk okay i
don't want to go to those uh june 17th
calls right now on gme because the
spread is high so you cannot buy and
sell them you know quickly so the only
way to control my risk on gme and
keep the spread i have is to use a stop
loss so i'm going to take a position on
gme at uh on the 30 minutes uh
simple moving average guys so for now we
are still five points away from it so
give me two minutes guys i'm coming back
but
sorry
but we we're gonna have some fun today
guys i told you
okay so i hope you like what is
happening guys and if you do smash that
like button it's important for the for
the channel okay give me some live give
me some love guys give me some likes
okay
we're gonna buy some jimmy shares soon
we already bought some amc
and we bought some spy okay so for now
we are making money on pretty much
everything and only the spread is losing
a little bit of money but it's very
negligible compared to the rest
uh
okay guys and talk to me tell me how you
feel about amc jamie what what do you
see on the other channels because as you
know guys i'm
very focused on my work you know i'm in
different projects i'm by the way
starting my nfts guys very soon i'm
going to show you that but i don't have
time to really hang out on the other
youtubers channels and checking what is
happening there so let me know guys what
uh what you think is happening right now
are the other youtubers talking about
squeezes uh right now or not am i the
only one that is saying that we still
have some time
uh it's interesting for me to know
so if you have this kind of information
share it please in the chat we can
discuss all of that
it's interesting of course to know what
the other um
you know traders youtubers i don't know
how to call them are thinking about that
but once again i can tell you that we
don't have all the ingredients yet
okay hey scott what's up bro
you like the look of bbig yeah bbig is
looking good i agree
because it's just consolidating above
the resistance lines so it's pretty good
what's the plan frame see today
the plan i so you probably missed the
the beginning of this video the plan is
to buy 10 000 uh us dollars of national
on the way down so we're gonna average
down
uh our uh position our entry
uh by buying 2 500 us dollars of uh
2500
equivalent
on of amc shares at 18.65 so we are done
here we bought slightly higher because
we bought a little bit after the open i
mean we bought here but we saw jme at
the open it was a bit useless trade but
then we entered on amc at 18.72
the next support level is 17.75 okay so
for now we have time guys
why
17.75 because it's the fib ratio that i
have here we might change that later
okay we're gonna see
we might definitely move it if we see
that we have another moving average that
is coming but for now this is the level
that makes the most sense so this is why
i'm having this level
uh and then we're gonna increase again
the position at 17 and around 16. okay
guys
okay so any idea what gamma mix gamma
max is for gme
so
i can show the gamma right now to be
honest
when you say gamma mx are you talking
about
the synthetic short interest are
are you really talking about gamma
because if you are really talking about
gamma actually the gamma is quite high
right now
okay we have some gamma that is coming
from the food options and we have some
gamma that is coming from uh the
sorry up
that is coming from the call options
okay so i'm retrieving all this
information
okay
so basically i i know where you're
coming from you're asking me about the
gamma because you're probably interested
to know about a potential gamma squeeze
okay so let me quickly re-explain what
is the gamma squeeze a gamma squeeze so
a squeeze is created by
any investor they need to buy on the way
up okay that are forced to buy usually
because they have a short position okay
so we can have a classic short squeeze
which means that an investor has a short
position and that he wants to and that
if he sees the price action is going
higher so he needs to buy it back okay
this is the usual
squeeze situation now a gamma squeeze is
almost the same thing but it's just
created by options okay so it means that
an option market maker because usually
this are the guys that are short calls
in this market because they need to
provide those call options to retail
investors and asset managers and
whatever so they usually have a short
call position so the shortcode position
they have is
on the strikes that retail and asset
managers are buying so on gme for
example you can see the strikes are here
okay
so bam bam bam
all right i don't know if you see well
let me know if you don't see well okay
so
here you can see the options are located
here
so we have a lot of option on the 200
strike okay it's the biggest one so
let's check
where
this
which maturity
is actually
uh
on which maturity is this strike so we
open all the maturities okay and we
check the 200 strike
bam
from march 25th man
okay i didn't see that
it's massive
okay okay march 25th but it's not even
uh okay so here we had so it's very
interesting to see what is happening
here guys on this weekly
um
on this weekly option expiry
we have
so you can see the monthly expiry is
here april 14th okay we have four
million shares
and on the weekly we usually have less
so here we have less 3.8 million
but
it's very concentrated because there are
less strikes available we can only go to
260 and are concentrated
around
you know between 100 and
uh 200 okay so this is creating a lot of
gamma as you can see the gamma is here
okay
so the gamma i compute my gamma here i
will not show you the formula it's a
black shot formula
but the gamma is showing you
uh what is the difference
of
exposure
for an option market maker
whenever gme is moving so i'll give i'm
giving you an example if gme is moving
by
one percent
today
uh
you can see the synthetic shot is
5.5 right now
if we go up by one percent
look at the synthetic short so the
synthetic shock is so the synthetic shot
you understand guys is the short
position beared by option market makers
and we want to know if this short
position is increasing on the way up so
this is what the gamma is doing so right
now
bam bam bam
so i put one percent so where where is
the synthetic short i'm looking for it
okay so the current 60 okay so the 5.5
million shares 5.5
percent uh compared to the market cap
now i refresh
okay so we have
0.2 percent okay so every percent jme
takes the synthetic shot is growing by
0.2 which is a lot so now let's say that
gme is taking i don't know
50
the synthetic short is right now at five
million shares
5.5
and it goes to nine so it means that if
jamie goes up by 50
option market makers need to buy four
million shares in the day
now let's compare this to the volume
that is trending on gme
so the volume that is training on gme
in one day
in a day like yesterday
15 million so you can you you guys can
see
in the 15 million shares that got bought
yesterday i mean that traded yesterday
maybe a quarter or a third of it is
coming from option market makers that
need to buy
gme shares on the way up to protect the
short call positions
and those shortcode positions are
absolutely massive
on the uh march 25th expiry okay
so let's see once again what is going to
happen by then
but uh probably
for now
um every move that is happening on jimmy
is amplified but once again so this is
the reason why we have this um premium
that happened on gme
but once again it will come back guys
okay
it will come back
the premium not gme so either amc is
gonna follow or um jamie is gonna drop
so let's find out
uh
you guys were talking about max payne so
i have here the max payne for april 24th
but it's actually very interesting to
compute the max pen for march 25th
so let's do that so i'm just gonna
invert those two maturities
okay bam
okay
now
as you can see
april is here march is here
okay i'm computing that
and i'm gonna check the max payne for
march 25th it's gonna be interesting to
know this information
okay so i need to do the same thing for
put options of course because the max
payne is uh
the sum of call and put options in the
market
the p l of all the put and call options
in the market so here it's not april
24th 14th it's march 25th
let me write it out for you
guys okay
so the maximum pain
is at 110 okay
but
i mean we are not really in a situation
where market makers
control what is happening okay we are
rather in a situation where they are
losing okay this is
this was the target okay for march 25th
they wanted gme to close 110. so
what is happening in reality
uh they are not you know coordinating
they are not calling each other and say
hey uh bro let's sell all together jimmy
chess to put back the price action 210
this is not what is happening what is
happening is that those guys they try to
maximize their own p l so basically when
gm is going higher they have a short
position that is happening and
usually
they have the choice to close it or not
every day okay they have some limit that
they can use
in the company
to keep a risk on gme and as long as
they stay in the limits usually when
there we have those strong moves that
are happening an option market makers
that is short gamma because he's selling
cool options to retail he's not gonna
hedge every day he's gonna try to
optimize his hedging so when i say
hedging it means buying shares on the
way up because he has a short position
short exposure that is created so he's
gonna he's gonna wait and he's gonna
hope the price action come back comes
back lower because lower you get you
guys understand that he doesn't need to
buy this shares anymore so he doesn't
want to buy shares on the way up and
sell it on the way down because this is
what he would need to do if jme goes up
and goes down okay this is a short gama
position it it makes you lose money for
every move for com to compensate that
you of course get a positive theta so
it's a daily um
a daily
how can i say daily premium that is just
coming to your account if you are
selling options okay
um
and so market makers usually they don't
hedge
i mean
they will not hedge everything they will
hedge maybe half of it so you understand
that basically they
participate into
bringing the price action
close to the levels where uh the
position started and this levels you
know are here it is the max payne so
it's not that you know once again
community community communicating
together maybe they do some of them
probably take the phone and call their
friends and say hey are you selling your
gme shares are you buying your jimmy
shares but i don't think they have
enough
um
exposure to really have uh an impact on
the market if only a few of them
coordinate okay if there are hundreds of
them coordinating all across the world
then of course it will have an impact on
the press action but i don't think
things happen like that
um
let's see
but the max pen is 110 but once again
they are for now i think losing it
uh they are probably very stressed right
now because they're probably for some of
them still have a short position
here so i guess they bought back maybe
some of it today at 130 i don't know
um
but
um i would i would say that i think a
lot of them still have a short position
that they didn't did not cover all right
and i think they can hold this position
at least until 160 they they have
probably already discussed uh these
scenarios you know in in their team with
their boss whatever and they probably
know they can handle a loss until 116.
now if we go above 160 i think everybody
is losing control and shorts are gonna
panic and cover all right until 160
i think that everybody is kind of okay
let's see what happens
uh booze are not ready to really
um you know reverse this so maybe they
will but uh i i don't think this is what
professionals think uh me included i
think we need more time
okay i hope i answered the question well
so what else you guys want to know so
once again like i said guys we monitor
what is happening on amc and gme today
30 minutes time frame we're using the 20
period moving average as an entry
okay so for now we are still far from it
we're gonna take a position on gme
whenever it comes here guys so for now
we have time we're gonna use a stop loss
to control the risk
okay and using a stop loss allows us to
take a bigger position okay this is what
is good about stop losses is that you
can you know
use leverage so you can buy a lot of
shares
with a small
um
if you have a tight stop loss and you
can you know
have big profits and a small controlled
loss okay so this is the beauty of it
but of course if you don't place or stop
us and your entry level properly
it will not work
okay so any idea what gamma max is for
jimmy just to answer to finish answering
this question the gamma is going to be
maximum
on um
on friday okay
so until friday there's gonna be a lot
of pressure
on shorts and
we can answer the question where is the
gamma maximum so look here i'm computing
the gamma
as you can see
and the gamma at spot is 4.3
just take this number as it is okay but
look for example what it was before
because i'm recording the gamma all the
time look the gamma is here so i'm
recording it since jan 22. okay i didn't
have it before i added it to my
spreadsheet so since jan 22
we have a gamma that is clearly
increasing and we have the biggest gamma
ever for now on gme okay i've never seen
such a big number
but once again i was not monitoring that
uh in last year so probably during last
year's quiz it was bigger than that i
don't have this information but for this
year it's the biggest one i've seen
now what is interesting is to see if
this gamma is uh growing or not on the
upside because if it is
as you as you guys understand the gamma
is what is creating troubles for option
market makers
because it's creating a short position
for them if jamie moves up
and if on top of this short position
created by the gamma the gamma itself
increases they have a double problem so
let's check that
so
we have right now a gamma at four point
three percent at spots i increased the
price action by ten percent
okay the gamma is stable
i'm gonna increase it by another ten
percent
okay so the gamma is stable so we are in
uh the range where they have the more
trouble
okay
but it's stable they have travel travels
everywhere
okay
okay it's and then it's dropping a
little bit okay so the gamma is big and
stable over uh depending where the spot
is
okay guys
stay with me i'm just gonna grab
something to it
um
okay cool scott happy you enjoyed it
okay guys i had a question from a member
in my discord
that is asking me
uh
what up the next resistance levels on
amc after 21
so i'm gonna try to answer that question
probably because he bought a lot and he
wants to take some profits early
and i don't think it's a bad idea
i will not do that guys because once
again
um
you know i don't want to sell any amc
shares i have unless you know it's to
buy back my jamie shares but i just want
to increase my position so that if
everybody does that it's good
but um the advice i can give you is take
profits early guys okay for now okay i
know you don't like to hear that
but we're still in an environment when
we're taking profits early is adapted so
what means taking profits early so
depending where you bought but 21
is the first area of resistance
that we have tested one twice once twice
three times okay
so
so it's becoming weak
and i don't think it will hold if we go
go back to it okay
but it's the first area of resistance
where maybe taking 10 20 of profits
is a good idea so that at least you can
buy back this 10 20
at 18
or 15 if we see it again
so i think it's a good process to to do
then
the next resistance level
is not easy to find
but i would say
it's not easy to find because we don't
have many reactions
i would say 24
okay if you don't know where is a
resistance level another tip i can give
you guys
you can use volume to guide you because
here as you can see
we don't have
many reactions
uh support or resistance that happened
in the 21
32 range but 21 32 guys is a move of 50
so it's unlikely that this move happens
in one time but as you can see sometimes
you know it
it is what happens
in this range amc always moves very
strongly so maybe next time it's not
gonna gonna move strongly i don't know
but maybe it will so
um
so to find the support levels whenever
you don't have these reactions you can
check where we had a lot of volume okay
so let's check the big volume days here
we have one okay i'm i don't know if you
see well guys
okay
i just want to see where we had a lot of
volume exchanged
on
amc in the 21 32 range
okay here another one
here another one
okay
it's not giving me much information
because i have a move here across this
resistance here it was because of the 21
support okay this one
this one happened on very high volume
and
it is not at 21 it is not at 32
so
now i know that i need to look for some
resistance support level around this
volume
and the best i can do is this okay
so you see guys
how i
managed
to find
a resistance level so it's not a strong
resistance but it's the best i can have
so it's 25.5 i'm gonna keep that on my
chart
and i'm gonna reply to my guy
okay
i did mvis bro adam
just check back
in the past
i did mvis
okay
okay so we're making some money
yesterday
six thousand dollars
our spy position is making money
that's pretty good
a good day for now
whoa jimmy
okay
jimmy guys
is moving again
it's a pain
it didn't reach
the moving average
let's see we if we had to close
not yet
okay once again guys this is a nice
consideration we were discussing
considerations
at the beginning and i told you that if
you have a nice consideration and then a
breakout above it is usually followed by
a move in the same direction so here
this consideration is not perfect
because i'm using the highs the closest
and not the the highs
okay let me know if you see well guys
but if we manage to close above it would
be a breakout so
two minutes left
at 10 45 guys
so you don't see them
you don't see what time it is but it's
10 44
so guys in one minute we are going to
close above this level so
there's another track we can do
we can buy some shares
okay so
10 minutes left
so we can go small we can go for 20
shares
if we close above that level
then
100 fund is going to be support okay
so let's play okay this breakout is not
perfect please do not follow my trades
guys because i'm just doing it to show
you a little bit how things work but
this is not a perfect situation but i
still want to illustrate
how you can use it
so it's not a financial advice and
please do not follow my trades uh here
i'm gonna
place an order okay we close the boat so
guys we have a close on the 15 minutes
time frame above the 140 level so right
now 140 is uh super easy support so
we're gonna we're gonna use the stop
loss so we're gonna use a stop loss
below the recent consolidation so the
recent consideration
is here so let's use a stop loss
uh
below you know what we're going to use a
trading stop loss
we're going to use this moving average
that is acting well okay so for now is
that 131 so we're going to place a stop
loss at
120.5
okay
and how many shares let's put i don't
know uh 250 dollars of risk in that
so let's compute that quickly guys stay
with me
okay
so we want to risk 250 us dollars we buy
at 404 points i told you guys don't do
round numbers so here let's be at
140.35
stop loss at 131 so we risk
the risk
so entry
stop loss
risk
per share
okay
again
9.35
and total
risk we want it to be 25 250
so so number of shares
is equal to 250 divided by
nine that we're going to round
okay
sorry
okay so 26 shares all right guys so
let's buy 26 27 shares
okay
at 140.35
okay guys
sorry i have some connection issues
again
let's set up this trade guys so i remind
you the trade we are going to do right
now we buy 27 shares at 140.35
we're gonna use the training stop loss
because we've seen that the 20 minutes
moving average is acting well as support
so we're gonna use that to um exit our
long position if things start to look
bad and it's gonna allow us to uh very
um
quickly neutralize our investment
okay
so we buy 27 shares at 140.35
okay
sorry guys i don't know why i'm losing
my connection all the time okay
okay 100
so 27 shares
140.35 okay not the round number we
place that order
okay it's placed now we're gonna place
the stop loss so we're gonna sell
27 shares
stop limit
below 131
okay
so the limit is 130
and the stop
level we're gonna take is 131 all right
guys
so let's place that okay our orders are
placed as you can see so we check we buy
27 shares
at
140.35 and we stop lost this position at
131 so we take a risk of 250 us dollars
which is a very controlled and limited
risk that we are happy to take we are
playing this breakout guys it's not a
perfect breakout let's just be very
clear on that guys
oh sorry i sort of lost the breakout on
the 15 minutes time frame
it's okay as you can see a good breakout
needs to happen after consideration on
low volume with the volume increase okay
let's have a look at that
bam we have a very small volume increase
but it's still a volume increase so this
is still a breakout it's not perfect but
it's still a breakout guys i'm here
taking a risk don't take the same risk
because this setup is not perfect i will
not share this trade with my discord
because i try to share with them uh
trades that first are done on a daily
basis some swing trading so we have time
okay there is no rush here it's on the
15 minutes time frame so i don't want to
do that second thing i told you guys
that this 15 minutes time frame is
controlled by a lot of algorithms and we
don't want to fight against them
third thing
um
this this signal is not perfect so i'm
here willingly taking a risk because i
think that things are looking good
uh and i want to play this i want to
show you a little bit how i take my
treads so this is the purpose of that
guys give me some likes if you enjoy
what is happening
um okay let me know as well if
if you don't um i don't know if you if
you don't like for example see me using
stop losses if it's really annoying for
you i need to know that i i i've always
traded like that guys so for me it's
natural
but you know i have respect for
amc and gme and for this community so i
don't want to
you know do things that
you guys don't like
okay so dan is bringing up
a nice and interesting theory
so
i'm happy to to to read your discussion
guys so do not hesitate to discuss
everything but i'm gonna comment what i
see
so i believe citadel is trying to set up
a bear trap with a fake gamma squeeze to
trap retail
yeah i know what you mean
uh
i know what you mean so how would be the
trap set the trap would be set
by
it means that citadel both these options
i don't think so i don't think citadel
bought these options because
it's too much of a risk so i think that
these options come from retail okay
because you can see the strikes that
have been used
so let's see how much money they would
spend
to do that
uh
okay so let's imagine just the 8 000
shares
here on the 25th
25th of march 200 strike let's see how
much this is worth okay
just to have an idea of how much this
trap could cost okay so we're gonna go
to gme
okay
okay we go to options
okay i don't know why my connection is
so slow guys sorry about that
okay
we take the 25th of march
you don't have it
okay march 25th it's here 200 strike
call guys
look
how crazy expensive it is the volatility
is just doesn't make doesn't make any
sense guys
okay
so here
i mean
i could sell this strike guys because
it's like
you know
the volatility is crazy expensive guys i
mean this should not be worth that much
so let's just imagine how they bought 8
000 shares here so it's like
it's not that much
in the end
yeah no it's it's small money india
yeah it's nothing okay in terms of
premium it is indeed nothing it's a risk
that is very likely uh gonna create a
loss but the loss is completely limited
so the probability of success is small
but the investment is not that much so
the theory would be that citadel is the
one that bought this
options
to create some
talks
on the
you know on the social medias why not
i don't know
i don't know
but then what do they do they buy these
shares
and then they probably buy shares i mean
you know because they know that first
they're gonna be buyers
and then they will take profit somewhere
this okay this would be the trap fair
enough but i mean i don't know if it's a
bull trap or a bear trap
okay we so you see guys we are moving
higher
so we we are not in this trade so we
still bought amc so we are very happy
about that
uh we didn't buy gme
but
you guys can see that this breakout for
now is followed by a move but don't
worry i don't think we go to 160 right
away we're probably gonna come back
and we're gonna have an opportunity to
get in we are we have our orders set
let's see if we are executed today
um
okay
we have our amc shares that are bought
as well so we didn't buy enough shares
to take profit here so we will not take
profit on amc
we will let it run
for now
and
we're gonna see what we do
okay so let's go back to the theory of
the trap
yeah why not they buy a lot of options
on very out of the money strikes which
cost even if the volatility is crazy
expensive they don't cost much
uh it creates a lot of talks on social
medias so the price is going higher they
probably bought shares as well and then
yeah so then they're gonna take profit
early so this is the story
they're gonna take profit profits early
uh so probably at 160 guys
okay
and maybe even before i don't know where
where they bought
but maybe maybe even before but the bull
trap is not here the bull trap to me
would happen if we have a move across
160 okay this would be a bull trap and i
will not fall in it because we had this
same boot trap happening here
and you know we have this kind of
breakout above 240
once twice and immediately it got sold
so here if we go above 160
to be honest it would look very good
and this would be a bull trap but for
now
uh
we don't have any bull trap set to me
but i understand where you're coming
from
so they will decouple amc from jimmy
okay i don't think they can really do
that
i mean
i don't know
i think that amc and gme will follow
each other whatever happens because
you know retail is very involved in in
this market and like i said investors
have memory and they remember what was
amc price when gme was worse for example
240 things like that
so sea death is big definitely but they
cannot have a long-term impact on the
on the price action of these two stocks
i mean they can have a short-term impact
definitely
but in the long run things will get back
to what they should all right
okay cool guys thank you for answering
my question about the stop-loss so i can
see that
no big deal for you
glad to hear that because it's it is
indeed to me the best way to take
positions
so that you can use leverage like i said
here it's a pen we didn't enter gme but
we will enter it soon i guess let's see
bam bam bam
okay so let's see guys indeed let's see
what's gonna happen come on we are 94
likes guys for those who didn't hit the
dislike button do it now let's reach the
100 likes come on guys you can do it
and let me know what else you you want
to see guys we are right now of course
monitoring amc and
amc is very strong guys we are coming
back okay let's analyze that guys on the
15 minutes time frame yeah thank you
guys 101 likes pop up here we go
so let's go in a 15 minutes time frame
and guys look it's in it is interesting
we are
coming again to the 21 level okay so
let's see what's gonna happen here
but
i think
we will maybe see a small reaction
a small rejection first
but maybe not
because gme you know is just
ripping
and amc is late so
maybe we're just gonna blow up this
level brutally let's see i will not take
profit here personally
because once again amc is late so if i i
don't want to sell amc if i sell
something i sell gme
okay and you see amc is like
arriving strongly this time on it
it's looking good guys
it's looking good we're making some
money today
nine
ten thousand
ten thousand dollars that's good pretty
good
okay
pam so it's good we both you see you
have often many opportunities guys to
get into a trade as you've seen at the
open we bought amc we sold some jimmy to
play the spread then we saw the price
action going much higher
and we
we managed to get in this trade just you
know before it was too late guys i think
we both here
uh sad support level so you see
this is
this is trading guys you always have
many opportunities you need to be
patient you need to try to go to what is
the most the more likely to happen
uh
this is what i'm trying to do when i
trade
okay we are in the spy trade guys that
is looking good as well
so we are making money
here oh yeah let's go quickly
okay so guys
let me know yeah edex running yeah bro
okay i'm gonna quickly have a look at
the watch list today guys we didn't go
through the watch list
this is what i'm using for my guys in
discord this is what i use to share my
trade ideas swing trade ideas
with them for the past six eight months
and of course it's not working all the
time but
i can tell you that most of the time my
alerts are good
and and i hope everybody makes money
this is the plan so here
bam we go
we take the alert bam let's check two
days
we have a lot of new alerts guys
so
tallow
you see guys talo is of course going
higher i told you that
yesterday this is an alert i sent you
already
okay nine as well has been sent
fisell guys we were monitoring fisell
and we said above 7.2 so we are not
there yet let's have a look at fiscal
but fiscal is looking good
okay amc is still guys you see this is
the typical uh situation we are
consolidating just below a resistance
but we are
close to it very close to it that's good
okay we didn't get rejected strongly why
because bulls are very strong so just
imagine how things work you have bulls
that buy buy buy buy and suddenly you
have a wall okay but bulls keep buying
and they keep like you know trying to
to go through this level okay and if
bears are strong they when they reject
balls then you know you have a strong uh
pullback whenever you don't have this
pullback but just a correction that is
uh very
um tight close to the cons close to the
resistance level
uh this is bullish and this usually
takes two three candles to break so here
we are in 30 minutes time frame
um
i don't know if i'm using the proper
time frame for this breakout
so
so it's hard to say i don't know but my
take is that we're gonna stay here
around
at least 15 minutes
from here and before maybe breaking it
i hope we get a pullback because i i
would like to buy some jimmy shares
at 140 i think we will have it okay
okay you know what we can do
okay
and at some point
we okay bam look break out
woohoo it's going strongly guys so it
didn't happen 15 minutes after
the first reaction like i said it's much
earlier guys look bam amc is breaking
out above the 21 level in life guys
it's brutal it's going strongly higher
so we're happy we didn't sell
the shares we bought before
so this is of course good we're making
some money here but it's not you know
amazing money yet gme is going to 160
guys all right so
yeah yeah we missed the
we missed the buying option
the buying opportunity here
i'm thinking if there is something smart
to do right now
i don't see anything
okay using the 21 level i'm trying to
give you some trades guys
but here for example we have a breakout
a breakout above 21. okay just like
jimmy broke out above 140.
we set up
uh buying um a bullish trade on gme
because we had this
nice consideration guys i remind you on
the 15 minute time frame that was
creating a good pattern that is tradable
uh so we
you know
we tried to make a bullish trade here i
mean we did the bullish trade but we
didn't get executed amc now you see
broke out but it's coming back and here
it's very risky to get in here
why because there was no consideration
at all before this bracket i told you
guys that maybe we're gonna take 15
minutes uh before breaking out and it
took two minutes okay
so um
so you don't have any
bull camp close to the breakout so no
boot camp no you don't know where to
place your consideration all right okay
so this is the issue so here i'm not
gonna buy more on amc right now if later
i see a consideration around the 21
level why not increasing the position
okay
it's totally
uh
totally acceptable but we need to have
some pattern we need to have something
here i don't have anything
okay
so it's not the right time yes to check
the watch list let's see what this
breakout is going to bring us let's
check the premium guys let's check if
emc is moving more than jme or not
what premium you have right now 21.5
148.75
oh
no
really you see it's back to 11 guys
now
am i doing it currently
oh yeah you see guys the premium so
everything is good for now
we are making money on all of our trades
the premium is back guys
to 11
so roughly the same premium we had
yesterday
uh
okay
so right now things are starting to
normalize a little bit we only have 11
difference between those two stocks
yeah something we didn't do guys let's
check what is the gamma on amc
okay and hit that like button for those
who have not done it yet guys i need to
know that you enjoy what is happening so
i'm gonna keep doing it it's important
for me
okay bam bam bam
okay so amc we said we're going to check
the gamma guys
yes thank you
is okay guys
i'm here
stay with me
okay bam sorry i was
a bit slow bam so we said
okay so this spreadsheet is not
refreshed as you can see i don't have
the correct price
okay it's good now
okay so
okay and this one is not refreshed you
know this is the thing with bloomberg
you always need to refresh your data
bam bam bam
say
all right guys
22.3 what the [ __ ]
okay guys bam
so
okay so you remember for gme we had 4.3
percent of gamma compared to the volume
traded this is what we need to uh to pay
attention to to know
uh how likely is the gamma squeeze to
happen okay we need a lot of gamma from
gamma squeeze to happen of course
and indeed on amc it's much smaller guys
we have only 1.4
percent of gamma
okay so three times less okay
so
this explains a lot of things this
is
showing us that
this is a lot of uh explanation about
the fact that gm is feeling at a premium
because when gme moves stronger
when amc and gme moves let's say the two
of them by 20
option market makers will need to buy
much many more shares
more shares
on gme than on amc because of this gamer
that is three times bigger and we've
seen that on gme we were talking on
yesterday's session about four million
shares
around one quarter one third of the
total volume traded during the day so
option market makers were
very much involved in this and once
again i don't think they closed their
position for all of them so today they
are still short they are not feeling
good and they probably are doing the
same thing as i do trying to you know
buy
okay jimmy is coming back
so it's a bit
okay it's coming back to 140 so we're
gonna buy here so let's check if it's
still good or not
because like i said the setup was not
perfect so basically what we don't like
we're not gonna buy if the pullback is
too strong okay guys
so let's check we go back on a 15 minute
time frame
okay
oh
it's addicting
oh right
happy to see
some french guys here with me in the
chat
but keep talking english guys everybody
understands okay so look guys we're
coming back
so here
i remind you the trade we have just set
up okay we've seen that we were
consolidating on low volume with 140
being the level above uh which
jimmy was not able to close on the 15
minutes time frame then we had a
breakout with a very small volume
increase it got followed by another move
with increasing volume guys that's good
okay we like to see that if the next
move was very weak it means that bulls
are not here right then probably some
profit taking that happened here i don't
know
um
i just don't want this move to be too
brutal
okay let's monitor where is our safety
line guys
our safety line is going higher now
132.5
so we keep our order guys we keep our
order we have
um 27 shares to buy
at 140.30
okay just above the support level guys
because this is how trading is working
we use supports we use resistances we
check the volume we check the volatility
we check the momentum whenever you use
those moving averages guys you are
actually
trading momentum okay because
across everything that is moving is
involving momentum so a moving average
that is crossing a price is a momentum
signal okay so if the price action is
crossing the moving average on the way
down it means that the momentum is
shifting you understand
okay i would like to get executed here
yeah spi is moving slightly lower
but
still up we still make money on our
trade
okay still ten thousand
okay i'm not worried spi is above the
200-day moving average we are not moving
strongly we don't have big volume guys
this is a quiet day on the global market
everything is happening today on the
meme uh stocks guys on amc gme on amc
and jimmy even the other meme stocks
nothing much happens guys
okay
uh we didn't get in guys we didn't get
in 141.5
let's see
maybe we're gonna get in later
okay look what amc is doing guys this is
good okay
look at that remember that i've i've
explained this already before let me
explain again
uh whenever we arrive on the
uh resistance
okay we don't like the resistance to be
broken right away this one was broken
right away bears immediately sold this
move all right i told you guys that guys
that it it happens too early and as a
result it got sold okay by bears
bulls didn't jump in the trade i didn't
jump in the train then we consolidate
here
and we find support very close to the
resistance area and you can see and you
can see bulls are trying to take back
control so this is of course very good
and like i said guys in a healthy move
up we like to see some poses okay where
you have new barriers coming in and
the buyers that before take profits okay
because if you don't have any profit
taking during the move up suddenly
everybody is going to take profit
together and
you're going to have some panic moves
and it's going to be dirty okay so we
don't want to see that if you want to
see a healthy bull run you need to have
those consideration all the way up
ideally involving low volume which shows
that you know bears are not fighting
like crazy is just you know a healthy
rotation of investors
and um
and yeah we don't like to see those
corrections too deep of course okay mc
is going back
so you see guys it's pretty interesting
what is happening so the spread has
uh reduced a lot
we didn't buy jme yet
we're gonna buy it guys
yeah i left hong kong
beeru is asking me
i left hong kong guys because it was
long time i was there
and i wanted a new adventure to start
guys that's why i quit my job that's why
i'm here in panama guys and you know i
just want to travel see see the world
do different things not work for a bank
anymore
and
and yeah let's see what's going to
happen
once again guys i want to show you that
uh
where can i show you that
guys we are creating our nfts uh where
can i okay i can show you that here
i take this opportunity to show you this
guys because like i said i quit my job
guys
but um
i
you know i have different projects i
have of course my discord i have the
youtube channel
uh
i'm gonna
also create a trading school guys in
dubai i'm gonna let you know about that
very soon i'm gonna be a teacher there
uh we're gonna have small groups only
that can come so i'm gonna let you know
all of that and i'm also creating my
nfts guys so i want to show you that
because uh
sorry up
because it's amazing guys it's really
really cool i'm very happy about this
project and we are about to really make
a killing guys with it
and i want you of course to help us grow
guys i want you to share uh you know
everything about
uh you know on our social media and
twitter and discord i want you to join
the discord but let me show you first
this
i can't find them
okay so i can show you that guys here
they are
so
this is the twitter
the twitter cam guest so we have 460
followers guys it's not enough
uh 1000 of you are watching this so give
me a like and go come on twitter guys
follow this page it's really you know a
project that is going to be amazing we
are going to
uh basically
uh
do some crypto arbitrage with gabrielle
that is you know a professional of this
technique and we're gonna generate
profits and if we can we're gonna give
you back the profits as rewards and if
we and if we cannot we're gonna spend it
for uh entertainment for different
things i really want to show you guys
those
crypto booths that i think look just uh
you know that that they're looking c
guests they're amazing we have different
families so this is the gangster family
uh the badass you know booze and we have
a lot of them and uh you're gonna love
it guys so follow us on twitter follow
us on uh discord
um
i really want to to push this project as
much as possible guys i believe in it a
lot and
and yeah thank you very much guys for
your support i'm counting on you
come follow us and let's go back to amc
gme
still fighting at the 21 level on amc
gme is still you know holding a little
bit above our
support level
and once again guys if you don't know
where to find the crypto bulls uh social
medias everything is in this description
of our of this video
the website is going to come soon and
it's really cool guys it's my little
brother that is making the
the website and it's my cousin that is
making the designs guys so this project
is really like a project that we we do
on our own and i think that we make
something that is really really cool
guys gabriel is involved in the project
as well he's helping us on many things
regarding you know the how to set up the
the nfts uh all the blockchain related
issues guys so he's the the smart guy in
this project
and and once again guys it's it's for
the channel and i want everybody to to
enjoy that so
like i said follow us come massively
guys talk about it make it grow
okay
jamie coming back
143
see
yeah yeah yeah
i can see my guys like here very happy
to see that
okay so
let me read a little bit that
okay so clove i can have a
look uh
okay okay okay so i can have a look
quickly at club guys but i want to stay
focused on what is happening on amc and
jimmy today
okay i hope you enjoyed this live guys
give me some likes if you do enjoy this
125 likes guys yesterday i had 150 let's
beat this
i'm happy to see that you guys stay
longer as well than yesterday so it
means you enjoy it which is very good it
means i will do it more often guys
clov
okay we can have a look at that quickly
so abayomi
i answered your question already i can
answer it quickly
again so the question is do you think
this is the start of the run up for amc
or it might end in a massive bull trap
so i don't know first thing
a bull trap will happen if we go above
122
this would be a bull trap
for now i don't have any buying signal
on the long term on my side i have some
buying signals on the short term that's
why i'm buying but i don't have any
buying signals on the long term yet
um
and like i said those are the levels to
monitor all right so you need to monitor
of course what is happening on the
option market so i will be doing that
because you guys cannot you don't have
the information but i'm here for that
and what you can do on your side and you
don't need me is to check this levels
guys okay
so
look amc 30 gme 160 spy 460 triple q 370
and vix 20 if the four
tickers i gave you first are above those
levels and vixx is below 20 we are
looking good okay this is a situation
for squeeze then we of course gonna have
a look at
um the short interest the option market
the correlation guys those okay let me
write it down because
it's important that you understand all
the ingredients of a squeeze i mean
no one can really know when a squeeze
will happen but at least if you know
what is creating it
so we need to have bullish momentum we
need to have asset managers in the trade
uh we need to have pressure on shorts we
need to have pressure on option parking
makers um
and we and we need to have all retail
and all um you know buyers like asset
managers or whoever that have those
buying signals on the long term so we
need to be above certain levels so here
correlation
so correlation with spy okay we want to
see this negative beta coming
what else
so synthetic short
gamma
okay those are what we are looking for
so for now we don't have a bull trap we
are bullish on the short term we are not
bullish on the long term
we have some nice moves up but this is
not enough information for me to know
what's going to happen
okay
jimmy is close to the target guys we are
going to buy some dmi soon
bam bam bam and you see guys the spread
is closing totally
amc is ripping
jimmy is waiting
okay
what do you mean so ahmed you want to
join the discord i mean i can say you
you guys don't see what is in the
description
um
maybe only when i post the video so let
me add
it here in the chat so that you can see
it guys
okay
okay
okay
okay
so guys i'm waiting for you
come on my discord
visit my website and come to crypto
bulls guys twitter discord help us grow
guys i'm counting on you
okay guys so we are still waiting
ah okay so scott baker invalid link
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
i will change the link sorry i thought
you didn't have access to that so
let me create an invite
okay
so this is for my discord
let me
and this is for crypto bulls guys
i want you to come there guys come on
come there bring your friends
for those who help us for those for
everyone that brings two members in the
crypto bulls discord
you can get white listed which means you
can get
uh the pre-sale price which is going to
be half of the public sale price so
it's good for everyone guys
cool
cool guys happy to see that
all right gme 143.4
let me quickly have a look at your
questions so
so rsi forward stem frame amc let's have
a look
okay it's over both definitely
um
it's overbought i agree but the bullish
momentum is strong the volume involved
are massive
so of course if you arrive
with over sold rsi and low volume on a
resistance level
i mean the probability it gets rejected
is very high
but if you arrive on a resistance level
with an over
both rsi with
uh impressive volume
then
it's more likely that it breaks once
again not right away so now what can
happen is that we consolidate and we
pull back a little bit to take back some
energy okay maybe like that
so maybe the rsa is going to come back
here
but
this is not enough for me i would not
set up a trade based on this information
because of the increasing volume you
need to have everything pointing towards
the same direction if you want for
example here to sell like like you guys
have seen i bought at 18.7
so i made
how much did i make but whatever i made
some money not a lot on uh today today's
uh price action and i don't i'm not
taking profits because
uh we are still bullish the probability
will go higher is higher than the
probability we go lower
that's it okay
so it's a question of probability so
once again to answer the question i
think the rsi is oversold overbought but
on increasing volume so
it's not bearish to me
oh so sorry about it yes i didn't know
it was making some noise
okay i will be careful now
but you know you cannot stay live four
hours and not eat right
okay jme
still high
okay
up 11 000
that's good
guys we're we're not in jme
come on
i want to see this pullback
ideally what i want to see is amc far
above 21 so that when jimmy pulls back
amc stays above 21 because let's be
honest i prefer to miss gme and see
everything going higher
because i have shares on both of them
but i would like to buy more definitely
okay guys stay with me i'm coming back
give me two minutes
okay
so
okay guys thank you for staying
alright
so
amc blue flag next leg up uh boots like
what do you mean no this is not a bull
flag for both leg to appear we need to
have a consolidation a correction for
now we are just moving higher so this is
not a bull flag maybe i don't understand
where you see the blue flag but to me
this is just one move up for now
and maybe we're gonna develop in the
bull flag between 18 and 21 it's
possible
let's see
okay
okay i'm response responding as well uh
to guys in my discord guys so i have a
question about tesla
that did a massive move
for the buy high strategy on tesla no
it's not time for that we are still not
in an environment where we buy high
so i wouldn't buy
tesla now but let's have a look
okay
so you guys can see i still have my
technical analysis from
i don't know when i did that
but i was expecting an abc
and i think we are in a b wave all right
we completed the a wave b wave as you
guys know occur in three
waves abc as well
so here i think that this is what is
happening and we have some resistance
here
okay
it's higher okay so we can very well go
to 1100 okay
here we don't have a breakout
the move around 900 was by a ball but i
don't know i didn't
it was not to the perfect setup to me
right now 1100 is resistance uh i would
definitely not buy there even if i see a
breakout because we need once again guys
to take back some energy we need to
consolidate it's very important
okay guys and as long as we don't have
this considerations as long as we don't
have the slow volume coming back
uh we are not in a situation where
uh upside breakouts are good to buy okay
guys so here we need time uh of course
the chat is bullish
but i would not be buying here
okay so this spy is still down
yeah i will change this link don't worry
let me update it
you're talking about my discord why
right not crypto bulls
come to crypto crypto bus discord guys
i'm waiting for you there
okay i'm changing it
in a sec
okay the link has been updated guys
let me reply
to
my members on about tesla so we don't
have any consideration of what happened
yet
gme coming back guys
are we gonna buy soon
i think we will
okay
it's perfect guys i told you we don't
want to see a brutal move to the 140
level this move happened in you know one
two three candles very quietly on low
volume so this is good guys i think that
140 will hold let's see we're gonna buy
here guys we arrive on our support papa
papa
oh
okay we done
we just bought some shares
cool
okay so executed here okay 27 shares
very good so let's see guys let's see
once again
like i said this setup is not perfect
but it's good enough for me to set up a
trade
um
don't follow my trades guys it's not the
purpose i just want to show you what i
like to do which doesn't mean that um
it's gonna work each time
here for example i can already see that
we have some
um you know increasing volume red on a
move down so this is not good okay so we
have two reasons to think the setup is
good but not perfect so for now you can
see we're dropping a little bit more
uh where is our stop loss so yeah we're
gonna move our stop loss because i
remind you guys that we are following
this moving average it was at 121 when
we set up our order it is right now
133.5
so we're going to increase that level
230 uh 2.9 to be just
above just below
okay
122.9 okay so we are already reducing
our risk guys you understand
okay
let's follow that let's see if we make
if 140 is holding or not i think it's
gonna hold but like i said
even if the setup is perfect sometimes
it's not holding
um
and here the setup is not perfect so
let's see if bulls manage to
defend the level
okay we can see amc at 21 jamie at 140.
you guys see the spread is
tightening now
okay let's see what is the premium 121
okay guys you see bam only eight percent
of spread guys
okay
so we you see how the spread has
massively reduced
since this morning we were that 17
percent of spread now we have eight
percent only
so it's very good guys
you know this is another style of
training you know you don't take a
directional trend you take a spread
because spreads you know they're
um
they are mean reverting
parameters so they always oscillate
around you know some value here zero all
right so whenever you see it's going out
of the range
then then you can try to sell it and
lock in some profits so here maybe it is
time so you see we are buying jimmy
shares
that we sold this morning
when the spread was at uh 15
now the spend is at 8
so now
instead
of
selling amc shares that we instead of
selling gme shares if we want to take
profits on the way up we can sell amc
shares you see because we are taking
profits not only on our amc and jme
trade but on the spread as well so this
is what we're going to do
if we see
everything is starting to rip again
we're going to start to take some
profits on amc because once again we are
locking we are locking here a double
profit
okay
but for now
140 is getting
worked by
bears
we are moving lower guys here
okay let's see if it is just a dip
for now as long as we don't close below
this 140 level on the 15 minutes time
frame
we are good because the signal was given
by
a close above 140 level
uh using
the closing level of the candle not the
highs and you can see we had a lot of
tails here above
so having a tail
is not a problem so here it's not really
problematic right now that we are below
this level
uh
but we don't want to see
the this candle closing below the 140
level okay
and any
way we're gonna have a stop loss once
again that is coming from the 30 minutes
uh moving average that is increasing
with with time so time is playing for us
guys okay and we're reducing our risk
slowly by doing that
so this is one method you can use when
you do day trading
okay
you guys have some issues with amc i
don't know on my side amc is working
well
okay come on guys give me some likes for
those who didn't
smash that like button yet 137 is not
enough guys
okay my side amc is working very well
no problem
okay jimmy is playing around 140 level
we are happy to be in
once again the time is playing for us
guys because this uh 20 period moving
average on the 20 minutes time frame is
increasing with time we didn't choose
this moving average randomly guys we
chose it we chose it because we've seen
that it's the best one that is the one
that gave us the best reaction in the
past you always need to do that whenever
you try to find a way to
you know stop-loss your position either
you use a moving average or you use a
consolidation okay ideally you do a mix
of both so here for example we could
use this moving average but whenever the
price action is going to come to it
maybe i'm going to move my stop loss
because here i have a consolidation
around 132. so
i can do whatever i want it's just
indicative okay and the best way to find
your stop-loss is to mix the different
methods and for those who are interested
to know everything about that guys how
to you know identify a good signal for
what reason you know i explained this
very well in my course i wrote 60 pages
guys myself where i give you guys
everything that you need to know to
trade breakouts consideration to read
the volume to read the momentum to use
divergences
i also give you guys all the different
entry levels and i tell you when it's
better to buy a re-test on the pullback
and when it's better to buy high i'm
giving you all the different techniques
to move your training stop-loss
so for those who are interested to know
about that this is gold guess you see
you can't find this anywhere uh
i i learned that uh because i was
working with some experienced traders
that taught me this i worked i learned
also by myself
uh it's not some book stuff guys i made
it a book because i wrote it down but
there are also eight hours of video
where i give you so many examples guys
um
trust me this is a very very very
precious information that i'm giving you
there so if you're interested just visit
my website guys and grab grab your
course join the community come to see us
on discord guys i'm working with
gabrielle you know we are here to you
know just share everything we know guys
we we're using very different methods
uh as you have seen guys gabrielle is
not joking he's taking like massive
massive positions
because he's been doing that for a long
time he has experience he knows what
he's doing he's making a lot of money
um you know i'm trying to show you with
a smaller portfolio small investment how
to trade because i think it's
interesting
um so of course i'm taking i have
different portfolios guys i'm also
taking positions for myself you know
that i don't share but what i share i
want everything to be doable for you so
this is what we do in discord
all right guys so let's have a look at
what is happening on gme pump for now we
bought we're happy it's moving higher
amc is moving higher the spread is uh
tightening guys so it's very good 143
likes come on guys bring me to 150 likes
you can do it
pam so let's have a look at this spread
you know what guys i'm going to use a
formula and tile off doing that so bdp
amc equity last price you see this is
the beauty about
bloomberg
is that it gives you
life prices i i mean i have 15 minutes
delay but it's very acceptable
okay bam
and so by doing that
i'm gonna have
the ratio with 15 minutes delay
okay so it's back to 10 percent right
now
okay for now we have a bullish reaction
yeah corey thank you brother
i hope you guys enjoy what is happening
this new format
okay for now it's looking great
so we bought 140.35
you see we have a small tail here but
it's not a problem at all like i said
guys we have seven minutes left we don't
want the scandal to close
below the 140 level
okay otherwise it would invalidate the
signal we had but for now we have a
bullish reaction guys bulla back in
control it seems
what we need right now
is some stabilization we had a pullback
so we had a breakout okay then we have a
pullback so this is totally
usual that's why we waited for this to
buy
we got executed as expected now we're in
the trade we are in a very good
situation because we have our training
stop platinum that is moving higher and
what we want to see guys is a signal for
bulls to know that now it is safe okay
because you have some bulls like me that
don't wait for that that just buy the
dip okay i like to do that but you have
other traders that are gonna wait for
one more signal so they're gonna wait
for example for a green candle so
whatever we're gonna have right now a
green candle on the 15 minutes time
frame oh sorry i'm at 30 minutes time
frame
it's gonna be the signal
that we are back in control so we have
six minutes left if this candle
is green
it's good
okay and for now
it is looking pretty good
cool bro i'm happy to see you enjoy the
stream
i'm enjoying it too guys
okay
amc found some support let's analyze
what is happening on amc guys
okay you see
now we have
okay so i told you guys it will take
less time what i said fifth at least 15
minutes i said two or three candles
so as you can see we have it
we had those two or three candles so we
have a tail definitely
now you see whenever you have this
so definitely as you can see guys i'm
having this level for a very long time
and i was right about that level as you
can see we had a fight here a
consideration now you need to move it
okay to match perfectly what happened
okay so either we put it here
okay i prefer to do that
now you see because i'm matching this
high
and i'm matching
here the support area
so now
this looks much better to me okay so
this is my new support level
okay 12 000 guys
making some money today
hey hey paula how are you
nice to see you
i hope you enjoy
i'm sure you're having a good day
because i know you love amc gme
everybody has is having a good day today
i mean except for shorts
okay
okay so i was checking clove guys
so i can keep taking it
first thing i see no volume increase ah
here volume increase okay
okay so club we maybe have some little
signals
but now you know
even if it was okay let me put the log
scale
okay i see better like that sorry i was
not using the appropriate scale you see
guys how it's important to choose
properly the scale you're using
if using regular scale unlock scale it's
not going to be the same
and here
okay it seems that we have um an incline
breakout above you know the three level
since then what is happening so it hap
so here we have some volume here we have
some volume but okay this could be the
breakout
it didn't really happen on volume i mean
it's not a very nice setup it's
definitely you know moving uh
up right now so booze and control
uh
but it can very well dump i mean it's
not the kind of setup i personally like
to trade
so i don't know if it comes i like
consolidations you see because it's
helping you to know who is doing what
where are those who are best
so here
i would use the consolidation i i could
buy if we get back to the breakout area
and we see some consideration but i
would personally stay away for now
being here is not great i think because
we have already you know moved up quite
a lot and
i mean not that much but a bit
and we have almost coming with an uh
oversold rsi and this time no volume you
see the difference i had a question
about the rsi
before
here the rsis of the boat soon
but look at the volume
so we are moving up
in a dangerous
uh zone area where we know bears are
going to attack
and
we don't have volume we don't have
buyers so
i mean
i don't like the setup
okay so you see for now good reaction
from jimmy
okay 147 strikes guys we are here
come on
bring me 250 likes guys
and i'm happy to see that you stay
longer as well
today
that's good
okay so emc broke out above 21 to i mean
20.6 now
so we are looking good so you remember
what we're gonna do guys if we see
today so how many hours left three hours
left
i don't know if i'm gonna make a break
or
or not
okay stay with me guys i'm just gonna go
smoke a cigarette i'm back in five
minutes
um
okay guys i'm back
oh jamie dropping when i was not here
a little bit back to the support area
we didn't have this green candle we are
waiting for yet so let's see maybe in
the next 15 minutes
sp why coming back as well
back to the support
so let's see if we have a positive
reaction on spy then probably we're
going to have a positive reaction on
amc and jimmy as well
here we are testing this support level
again guys
cause all right so we can have a look
quickly at the
okay so here we're dropping a little bit
so let's move our stop loss a little bit
higher here guys
because once again we follow the 20
period moving average on the 30 minutes
time frame guys this is our safety line
here on this trade 125
134.7
so we're gonna move it to hundred and
thirty
okay we take a little bit of
room
here
bam updated
we can have a look at bitcoin quickly if
you guys are interested so what is
happening here
we are consolidating guys around this
level so bitcoin is trading at 42 500
right now
um
so on the short term
we have
this
resistance level at 42 000
roughly 5
200 okay so we are above that so for now
on on the short term so we broke above
this level we broke out above this level
uh that was acting as resistance for the
past
let's say 10 days
we are still above that so those are
still in control on the short term but
on the medium term guys we have this
resistance that is here at 42 43 000
so let's see if we manage to consolidate
here a little bit between 42 and 43 000
this would be looking good
um
for now we don't have the big volume we
are waiting for guys once again
for both to really take back control
here on the um on the medium term
we need bitcoin to you know have this
massive
green
volume above an important level so it
can be the 43 000 level for example if
we see this consolidation happening a
little bit longer on low volume which is
good right now so this is looking good
and if we break out above 43 000 then
with volume increase this would be a
very good signal for the medium temp so
we'll probably push towards the 50 000
level if this happens
uh for now we are not there yet for now
we are testing the levels so let's see
what's gonna happen
um
i don't really know what to think of
bitcoin guys everything can happen it
can it's gonna be related to the global
market as well
so as long as spy is above this 446
level
i mean we are safe on pretty much
everything
but let's see if we manage to stay above
that level
uh today and until the end of the week
it's going to be important of course to
see
okay let's monitor the spread between
amc and jme guys
so right now we we were having nine
percent
ten percent uh premium on gme
right now is five percent guys so you
can see that this spread that we sold at
11
is already uh making some good money
i mean the position was not big but
we managed it was trading at 17 during
the day now it's back to five percent so
whenever we can we're gonna try to take
some profits on this spread okay
so it means that we need to sell some
amc shares because we bought amc we
bought gme
so it seems too early to sell amc shares
but what we can do
is either to sell on the way up it's
better or we can also take profits on
the spread by instead of using
a stop loss on gme we can use a stop
loss on amc so we're gonna see what's
gonna happen if gme comes close to the
135
area
uh but maybe we're not gonna sell gme
maybe we're gonna sell amc so we're
gonna see once again we are selling long
which means that we sell some shares
that we bought
hey bro so would you sell some would you
sell now amc cc
for a high target for end of week
i'm not sure to understand the question
ah call calendar what is cc
cash
close cc in banking is cash closed
can all calendar call but
covered calls okay my bad bro i was
close um yeah i think that uh covert
calls are good
on amc once again
we are above the 21 level so it's good
to give it a chance as you can see buzan
control so maybe we can rip 225 i know
it's far
so i doubt we can do it today it's 17 to
move up so it's
pretty unlikely let's be honest
uh but the volatility is high so it
makes sense to sell calls yes
it makes sense to um
and it makes it make sense to sell this
high volatility if you have shares it's
good uh so you can go to you know
maybe the 25 strike which is the next
resistance that i doubt we really go
above in april for example so an idea is
that every 100 shares if you want to
sell some covered calls to get some
protection
every 100 shares let's have a look at
what we can do on amc we can go to april
you don't lose the shares of course so
you keep your shares
and sending some cover calls is good
guys so 25 strike for example on april i
don't know if it's worth that much
let's see the price
okay it's 1.7 points so it's not amazing
but it's still 1.7 uh
us dollar per 100 shares that you get uh
that you get back in
a matter of three weeks so i think it's
good look at the volatility the
volatility is at 140 percent
it's a lot the realized volatility is at
uh 9.99
only so the realized volatility is the
fair price of this volatility so you can
see here that market makers are using a
premium of 40
on this volatility so let me just show
you what impact it has on the price
using 138 volatility the air pro 25
strike call is worth 170 if now i use
the fair volatility at 99
look at the difference in price we go
from 170 to i don't know 0.9 maybe pam
you see 0.9 guys so you have a premium
of a 0.8 us dollar on this so basically
it's double the market option market
makers are selling this option twice the
price to get protection okay so it's of
course good to sell
if you have shares of course
so this is an example you can go to the
april 25
or you can go to the april 23 24
whatever i would go to the april 25
personally
okay so we can even do that if we want
to take some profits today and keep our
shares we can also uh sell this covered
call i think it's a pretty good
strategy
okay guys it's pretty quiet right now
the volume is lower as you can see
volume is decreasing so everybody is a
bit waiting
we are still hovering around this 140
level
uh bulls are definitely in control as
long as we stay above this 30 minutes uh
moving average 20 period moving average
on a 30 minutes time frame
amc is looking great guys
like i said this
spread has totally guys
uh tightened today so we need to take
profits on the spread that we opened at
the end at the beginning of the day
uh bam bam bam
so luke the spread is here guys four
five point six percent
i don't know if you see well now it is
okay six percent
so the question is 30 minutes your
preferred during time frame no no i
don't have any preferred time frame i
just take the time frame where i have
the best reactions on the moving
averages all right because it's telling
me that this is the time frame that most
traders are using okay
and here as you can see on the 30
minutes time frame you can see how well
this moving average in blue here is
supporting the price action okay we have
one perfect reaction two three four
five six seven eight nine
nine of perfect reactions in the very
recent past so it's beautiful so you
need to take this into account so this
is the right time frame to to use the 20
period moving average but you know you
can switch to time frame switch the
moving average go to the exponential
moving average whatever you need to you
know play around with this and see what
is fitting the best
guys we have oh
it's closing
i want to see this green candle you're
going to see guys whenever we're going
to have a green candle here it's going
to be a good signals for bulls to get in
we are now consolidating taking a little
bit of
energy
i don't have the rsi here i don't know
why it disappeared but it's good to keep
an eye on it as well
okay
so you see we were having a very
oversold of a very overbought rsi on the
30 minutes time frame now it's back to
normal all right we are but now we're
having an rsi of 65
so we have reloaded some energy to push
higher so
let's see what's going to happen
okay spy is still at the support level
guys
okay so we need to find some levels to
sell some amc shares today guys we're
gonna close a bit the spread that we
opened uh
at the beginning of the day
so 25 seems
not
reachable today
so
let's try to find another resistance
level that is closer to that
okay
22.2 is one because i have here some
reactions as you can see one two three
four five reactions
so 22.2 is a level so we can sell some
chess here but it's not very ambitious
um
okay jimmy is still hovering around this
140 level
to particularly
okay the spread is at six percent guys
so how many shares did we buy 134 right
this morning of amc
so we can take profits on this 134
shares and just close our spread okay
guys so we are we i remind you what we
did we took a position on the spread we
bought amc we sold jimmy
then we bought some amc shares at 18.7
and we bought some jimmy chase at 140.
so we can now
take profit on
amc
by selling the shares we bought this
morning at 18.7 and disclosing the
spread
so i can see the price action cannot
really now move higher okay we are a
little bit stuck here
okay
the resistance level is here
at 21.9
so let's put a selling order guys here
at
[Music]
what was the highest level that traded
here
okay we went to 22 22 has been hit
so
21.75 seems
a good target so let's set up a trade
here we're gonna take
profits on
uh one of our two buying orders so we
are still both shares today
uh we're just gonna you know reduce a
little bit by 124 shares
here we're gonna sell it at 21.75
okay
okay so we placed the solder guys
because it's good to take some profits
guys when you have good trades so that's
you know if things go against you you
can redo your trade so for now we didn't
take we opened three positions three
winning positions we didn't take profit
on anything so we need to take a little
bit of profit uh just to you know be in
the right mindset
okay and i can see that
you know things are slowing a little bit
okay we have gme dropping again coming
back to this level
not amazing
except
okay let's see what's going to happen 21
is still support so what we can do yes
here once again to control the risk as
we see
we have some we have a deep
happening right now
it's not a big deep but we have a small
dip happening
um so what we're gonna do
instead of using a stop loss on gme
we're going to use a stop loss on amc
okay
so we need to find a level below which
this position is good to stop so
20.3 is not amazing i would prefer to
sell on the way up
i'm not gonna do anything for now i'm
just waiting
but after taking back this level what i
miss here this is the reason why i'm
starting to think about taking profits
guys because
um
you know we have a breakout once again
the big volume here was on the red
candle and then the volume is dropping
all right
so
it's showing a little bit that the
momentum is shifting
so i don't know if it's gonna be a fake
out
but i can see the price action is
dropping a little bit
and we have still nice profits so we can
lock some of those profits
okay
jim is coming back close to this
uh
20 period moving average on the 30
minutes time frame
so as long as we're above that bulls are
still in control
amc same thing but as you can see as
we're starting to have this red candle
that is not very nice quite
strong
uh good question so ud why selling games
he says if i think it can go higher
because like i said open three positions
today
uh even four
and i am right now in good profits so
taking a little bit of profits on uh one
of those positions makes sense so that
you know
you're in the right might set because if
you make some profits and then you lose
everything
you still have your position you don't
really know how to handle it you start
to lose money it's not a good mindset so
to be in the right mindset mindset and
take the right decisions it's good to
take some profits uh whenever you have
it and here we have three positions the
three of them are winning so we're gonna
think of thinking of taking some profits
so i'm checking
what levels and and also i'm seeing that
the price action is getting weaker
uh on the 15 minutes time frame
so i think that it's appropriate to
start to think of of that
we can see gm is coming back to this
level for now we still have our stop
loss here
at so now it's at
134.6 our stop loss is
let's monitor that
our status is at
133.9 so we still have some room but
we are testing this level
once again i don't like the candle that
is happening right now so let's see if
bulls manage to you know
give back some energy to this move
if it's gonna fade
but i don't like what i'm seeing because
this move is happening quickly guys
it's never good it's broken a bit it's
breaking a bit the dynamic
that we had
on the short term of course on the
medium term the dynamic is still good
but
uh
i know that i will close some of this
position today so i don't have that much
time left to do so
and when you're in profits closing
position is never a bad thing
okay so here we are coming on this
moving average
soon so let's see if it holds
here as long as we are above the 21
level we are good guys
i mean even 20.6
so i'm gonna place a stop loss at 20.45
just below guys
if i'm getting out on a dip it happens
it's part of the game
but
like i said i'm controlling the risk
so we have here are taking profit order
for now we're gonna deactivate that are
we gonna change it can i change it here
yes
okay
so the stop is gonna be at 4
20.45 we said
we can't we don't like round numbers so
40.44
and here we're gonna
hit the bid 40.3 okay so now we save
okay we still have very decent profits
today
jamie dropping a little bit
let's see what happens on this
30 minutes
moving average
you see here if i have sold my amc
shares higher i could have bought some
gym more gme
but right now i don't want to keep
increasing this position uh before
taking a little bit of profits
so let's see
what's going to happen here
we're going to have a reaction soon so
if gme holds well above this
20 period moving average
on the 30 minutes time frame
it's going to be looking good okay we
can have here a positive reaction coming
soon it's going to help amc as well to
move higher as you can see bam
okay guys so yeah we there's nothing
much to do we wait
we wait and let's see what's going to
happen 21 is holding well for now
okay we have a little positive reaction
on the 21 level
okay
indeed
good comment
vince
we can see the on the 15 minutes time
frame the sp y is going below this
446 mark we have our stop loss on this
position so we are fine
um
but it's possible that we see indeed
something happening so let's see
we are ready
to you know reduce our positions on
everything the risk is totally under
control
but we can
indeed start to see
some things that we don't like so
probably those are going to take back
control but now we have some
you know
it's a good time for the bears
can you see gm is coming on this moving
average so probably if we go through it
we're gonna have a move quite strong
because stop losses are here
our stop loss is just at 123.9
so we're very good with that
we have some room
okay
we are in a
interesting situation guys let's see
what's gonna happen
let's see if both can back can take back
control you see
for example i am not buying i don't know
what the other investors are doing
the volume is getting lower
come on guys come on
so
okay positive reaction guys
for now
it's good
as you can see this 30 minutes moving
average is doing its job very well for
now
okay so now we're gonna think about
taking profits on the way up and not on
the way down which is of course better
so let's wait a little bit we have our
order at 21.75
[Music]
but something is telling me that okay we
have nice profits guys eleven thousand
okay
okay i'm just gonna take profit here
guys
because
i feel something is not
right for now
so just reducing a little bit the risk
bam
okay
so the mc the amc trade
is closed guys with a nice profit
we have i have also of course uh still
our shares on amc shares on gme guys
it's just
taking a little bit of profit on this
trade
now here we are very good because this
moving average is moving we are
basically right on on it so the risk is
totally controlled here
okay spy
is coming back as well a little bit
okay guys
okay we can quickly have a look at the
rest of the market so bitcoin still
stuck a little bit here guys
dbig completely frozen
but i'm not surprised because everybody
is trading you know amc and jamie today
so
this makes sense
okay she's dropping a little bit
but still strong
ah let me see jimmy jeep
dipping a little bit
we are testing this level it has been
tested many times
for now we don't have any
volume involved
but we are definitely at an important uh
it's an important situation
because if we go across this moving
average with some volume increase
it will not be looking good guys
i mean only for the short term okay
let's make the scenario what's gonna
happen guys nothing bad all right
nothing bad at all we have next support
at 130 uh
but is it strong
110 is quite strong right so even if we
break below this we can still you know
have some support around 130 but the
reason why i'm personally using that as
a stop loss is because this is the
strategy i decided to do today okay so i
need to stick to that but doesn't mean
that it would look bearish it just means
that we're gonna be neutral between 130
and 125 again below 130 it's not good we
don't want to have a close today below
this level
but for now the 30 minutes time frame is
once again
20 day moving average is doing its job
okay
so let's have a look at some mulan ic so
i can have a look at that
not moving much i discussed that before
ready it's quite good to see that
here i could definitely set up a trade
but for now i have um
already three positions to manage so
it's enough for today but tomorrow i can
do that on other stocks if you like guys
to see that here you could buy at 290
stop plus 250 or 260 because we have
this consolidation that is created just
below the resistance level at 360. so um
what could happen in this situation is
that we considered a little bit more and
then we break out with volume increase
this would be looking good uh but the
alternative scenario is that we get
rejected and then the next support area
is much lower around two this is the
reason why using a stop loss around 260
is appropriate in this situation
okay
so i'm gonna stay with you guys at least
15 minutes more i want to see
if this 30 minutes moving average is
holding well
and then i need to eat
for now is holding
and how high it can go i didn't answer
the question so how high it can go
okay let's
let's be bullish let's imagine we
consolidate and we break out with volume
then the next resistance is four is five
is it a strong resistance okay to know
if a resistance is strong you need to
check how many reactions you had in the
past and did they happen on a high
volume so i mean the volume before this
was extremely low so it doesn't mean a
lot
but we had five reactions here and here
it was the lower band of the gap up we
had just before so i would say that this
resistance is
not very strong especially if we arrive
here with strengths
but
it is a resistance then the next one is
seven so my
uh the natural
targets are between five and seven now
if things really really get bullish but
i don't know if it's the case for now
uh it's very hard to say we need to to
know how the price action will react
around this levels but if we arrive
around 720
um we have the 200-day moving average
that is coming did he direct well before
he didn't give very good reaction so
it's a resistance but not very strong uh
and then we have this gap that is here
located around 11.75 so some say we can
go there i mean of course it's possible
but for now we are far from that
um so i think that you know taking
profits between five and seven is
appropriate on this uh trade
okay
and you can of course let ten or twenty
percent run uh of the total investment
that makes sense as well
okay so for now
we are holding well guys
once again i told you that after this
breakout that was not perfect above the
140 level we want to see
we want to see a green candle
so in five minutes but this green candle
is too weak and it happens before this
level so if we manage
within five minutes to close above 140
this would be a good signal sent to the
uh bulls and to the best as well that
will just retreat probably
um
right now i think they are around 140
okay
so let's see if we manage to have that
okay
cmc coming a little bit lower on the
very short terms bezel i took back
control
but once again no big volume so for now
it is all good
okay
okay we have we can see the 30 minutes
um time frame
20 period moving average is flattening
so um
as it is flattening
the stop loss we have just below this is
not growing anymore so this we arrive in
a situation where our risk is uh stable
when it was reducing before so it's
slightly
worse than before
okay
i joined right now can you please show
quick what can happen with gme so what
can happen with gme
okay so let's go back guys because here
i'm doing some day trading because i
think it's interesting for you to see
how it is working once again
uh sorry for those who get annoyed by
that i see some messages that you know i
understand i understand that you know mc
and jimmy are legendary stocks and you
know i understand that some of you don't
like to see day trading but some of you
like it so i'm doing what most of you
like
and i'm doing what i enjoy doing and
what i know how to do so i'm here to
spread some knowledge guys i hope you
enjoy that
so daily time frame let's take a step
back what can happen so we are both the
120 level 120 level was a strong
resistance created by many many
reactions before all right we took back
this level but we took it back without
any consideration just before it
happened so this breakout is not
reliable so it can very well fake out so
um given the volume increasing on the
way up that we see bulls and controls so
as long as we stay above 130 i would say
that uh going 260 seems almost
inevitable okay that we're gonna keep
keep going higher as long as we're above
130. now um
if we get if we go below 120 we have a
strong uh support at 115 which is the
last breakout we had so this would
probably be a very nice area to uh to
buy so that's why i personally will stop
plus my position here that was once
again done using some day trading
techniques to show you how it works
uh maybe i will reopen something 120 30
i would see but i don't like the setup
it's not the setup i like to trade so
it's not a good you know day trading
setup if we go back to 150 this is much
better because this is a stronger
support so it's better to buy
now for the bullish case if we go to 160
we're probably going to see a first
rejection then we need to see some
consolidation we need to know what is
happening on the option market we need
to know what is happening um
you know on the volume on the volatility
and if we go above 160 this would be
looking very good so this is what you
have missed brother
okay guys we are coming again so one
minute left we are not gonna close with
a bullish candle i'm afraid
on the 15 minutes i'm fram two seconds
left
okay it's a red candle
so let's see if we manage to
to bounce from here
okay everything is a bit stuck right now
we are really in a wait and see mode
so nothing much happening you can see we
have those very low volume trading
okay you so guys it's the lowest volume
we had
on the 15 minutes time frame
since the beginning of the day
so just showing that you know
nothing much happens and in these
situations you know investors just take
profits
just like i did
okay guys i wait with you till the end
of the next candle so 14 minutes and
then i'm gonna make some food
give me two minutes i'm coming back
okay guys i'm back i can see we're still
holding
there
and guys
i have some big announcement to make
gabrielle who is hitting who is sitting
here with me created his tick-tock
channel guys and he's sharing uh you
know some market updates
he's uh also sharing sometimes his big
days p l guess so you can go watch the
past videos you have some really big big
days where he made like 150 000 you know
things like this right
yeah yeah sometimes he's making really
big money sometimes he's losing 100k you
know in one day so this is training all
right guys so if you're interested to
follow that uh i'm gonna share the link
of his ticker channel guys go massively
follow him guys his videos are really
cool really funny you're gonna love it
i'm sure it's trading
trading point update so what so do you
have a link uh i'll send it to you okay
so that i put the link in the
description so that everybody can follow
gabriel's tiktok guys i'm counting on
you
okay so you see i'm talking about that
and jimmy is feeling better
finding some support on this 30 minutes
moving average so you see guys when you
have those
moving averages that you find them
properly it's really helpful to know
what is happening all right right now we
know who is in control we know that
boo's in control
and you know it's just very
you know you feel good when you you do a
trading because you know you are on the
right side sometimes it's get broken and
then it's coming back it happens as well
all right so there is nothing
um
guaranteed about anything guys this is
trading
send it to you on whatsapp okay
foreign
[Music]
oh red guys this is
checklist
okay guys so we are here on gabriel's
tik tok
should
okay i'm just checking it's working well
okay guys here we are so you have a lot
of videos you have things like that so
here he made for example hundred and
seventy thousand us dollars
okay guys so if you want to have some
fun you can you know just go across
his videos there are a lot of market
updates as well he has only 1 000
followers guys so make it grow help him
okay i'm sending the link here
i'm sorry guys to spam you with all
these things but
you know
maybe some of you are interested to to
watch that i'm gonna add it in the
description
and go there guys you're gonna see
you're gonna have fun you're gonna enjoy
what he's doing
all right so i'm gonna add it in the
description
you see and jimmy's coming back guys
right away you know good vibes
so gabriel's tic-tac
bam
okay so i want to sell my shares
at e to row average 147 dollars at a bit
loss then buy
or add a b
carry for computer share
okay so the question is you want to do a
swing trade you want to exit and
re-enter lower
um
so if you want to do that you need to
use some resistance levels okay
here
as you have seen on the daily time frame
we don't have any resistance
right now we are i mean we have a little
resistance 140 okay but we are coming
back above this level and the next one
is 160. so taking profits at 160 guys i
know you don't like to hear that but it
is a good move not financial advice but
we've we didn't test this level for
quite some time
and
um
and it's and it is a strong resistance
level all right so you can expect to see
a rejection the first time we arrived
there so if you want to do a quick
screen thread you can sell 159
and you can
buy back what do you want to buy back
computer shares and you can buy it back
then if you don't want to take too much
risk i would say around 140 and if you
want to take more risk 130 all right
something like that
okay guys seven minutes left in this
live i hope you enjoyed that give me
some likes guys 103 likes give me more
i can see there is a little delay maybe
with the video
but
i hope you enjoyed that
come on make it grow guys 164 you can do
better than that
okay look jme we're gonna stay with
jamie guys till the end
still above this
moving average that is not growing
a strong move up now would be very
welcome guys let's be honest we need it
we need both to take back control
we are waiting for this green candle for
quite some time if it could happen now
above the 140 level it would be a good
signal
so let's see
spy is coming back a little bit as well
guys we are you know a bit in a
dangerous zone here
hovering around this
important support levels on amc and gme
on spy
of course we are still bullish guys on
the
medium term i'm here talking really
about the hourly what is going to happen
in the coming hours guys
okay amc papa finding some support here
that's looking good
okay
thank you very much for the good
comments guys i really appreciate that
thank you for being here
with me
i'm gonna once again try to do that
every day when i'm in panama then guys
i'm gonna move back to asia so
okay then it's gonna be hard for me to
make some lies but if you guys really
love it
and you know
things are going well maybe
okay guys i'm so sorry i need i need to
go because i have some call
so uh thank you very much for watching
much love uh thank you very much for
being here
uh give me once again more likes guys
it's really helping the channel and i
see you tomorrow see you guys